[Music]
hello everyone
welcome to this agilent scrum full
course by simply learn
in this session we will tell you
everything you need to know
to become well versed in the concepts of
scrum and agile
in less than 4 hours our instructors
chandra
rahul and ishan will be covering topics
like agile
scrum agile project management agile
user stories
scaled agile framework how agile
waterfall
scrum and kanban are different from
one another and many more we will also
be guiding you
on how you can become a scrum master we
will be learning
all of this in under 4 hours so without
any further ado
let's get started but before we begin
make sure
you have subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to click on the
bell icon so you never miss an update
from simplylearn
welcome to agile tutorial from simply
learn i am cmr
chandra mr a professional consultant and
coach
certified agile scrub master pmp
principal practitioner
itl for managing professional kobit 5
and devops
as part of this video tutorial we are
going to understand what is agile
the basic details one should know about
agile
to understand this better let us look at
a time
in the late 90s what was happening with
software development forms
so they used to follow waterfall
methodologies so
there is to be expression like sir we
have a problem
so what happened so our client want a
new feature to the software
we are already midway creating the
software we can't add
the feature so what does it mean
so there is a scenario where the change
is asked
so why change change may be because of
adding certain features removing certain
features modifying certain things
already given
what is wrong in that why can't we do
the change so now
point here is not about doing the change
itself it's about the effort
additionally it takes
cost money in terms of which is going
out
the effort then the scope which is going
to change at the same time
you also need to put more efforts which
will delay the project
so now is it okay so 90s
it was okay today is it okay a big
question mark so why is that not okay
so may to understand that very clearly
right
i knew we should not have used the
waterfall methodology for development
so is that an issue with the waterfall
methodology so answer is
no if it is today's scenario the answer
would be yes if it is 90s answer would
be no
so what changed in this 20 years or 15
years
the dynamics of the market changed the
behavior of consumers changed
so if you look at anyone who is using
any product it may be a software product
or a hardware
like if your mobile phone or a
television or any application mobile
application or
application used on your systems the
upgradation of the new features and
functionality of that is
improved more and more and consumer
wants it more
and you have a very less time to respond
that is one thing
second thing there is lot of competition
if you do not respond quickly
competition will take over
so for you to sustain and grow it is
very essential
that you understand this dynamics and
you need to respond quickly
which was bit difficult when it comes to
approach what is called waterfall model
now how do we address this so what is
that waterfall model is
all about why is it difficult for us so
the methodology where waterfall
model is used involves teams following a
series of steps
and only going forward after the
previous steps are completed so there is
a wait time involved
so until the previous steps are
completed only then i can move to the
next
so it is a slower thing it would take
certain
longer duration so it is best used in
the scenarios where the teams are small
and the project is expected to move in a
predictable manner so predictability is
very important when we follow waterfall
methodology predictability
the variation should be as lesser as
possible so what is the predictability
i'm speaking about
as i create this product as a result
comes up if it takes six months one year
two years three years it's okay so this
is how the product would look like
the predictability how the product would
look like how that particular output
would come so when is that going to come
is it okay
if i bring that result after two years
is that okay
so if everything is okay that way
without very less without any variations
as such very less variations
then it's fine so because of following
waterfall model
uh what is that methodology what is that
flow
we need to understand that so
requirements gathering and documentation
is the first thing what used to happen
which is true in agile methodologies
also
but the main difference here is the
requirements gathering and documentation
happens in detail a comprehensive one
now once that is signed off only then it
is more to the design
now based on that requirement which is
gathered which is full comprehensive
then the design will happen based on
that the consideration of
process the products the people the
environment
then the design happens which is again a
detailed design
now once the implementation starts if
you find
any deviations the correction needs to
be done since
the design is in detail the deviation
possibility is
as less as possible but the challenge
comes up when the dynamics
in the market when the dynamics of
customer changes
customer asks for change then you may
require to do the change
now when you want to do that change you
might require to do
the change only after understanding what
would be the impact of this change in
the entire output which you are going to
create which is very comprehensive one
so because of this it consumes time it
consumes extra effort
so it may be a scenario where the scope
of work is reduced as well
even after that this exercise has to be
done which will delay the project
so this was okay so when this model when
the
things were done things were taken up
for changes it was okay because the
consumer behavior as i mentioned
there is a lot of wait time for the
consumers also so there was less
competition but today it is not i need
to go quicker
so because of this what are the
disadvantages which just came up
to the consumers or to the organization
who actually follow waterfall
methodologies in today's scenario
so what could be those so making changes
would be difficult as i mentioned uh
earlier so then it doesn't focus on end
user client
customer perspective value so today i
think more and more we're speaking about
creating a value in the consumer
perspective customer perspective and the
time it takes for consumer to realize
the value how long it takes
the more it delays in realizing the
values by the consumer
there is a delay in terms of making your
product impression better in the
consumer's mind
so competition will take over so your
existence will be in
bigger threat so testing phase is
delayed until most of the project is
completed
because it has to follow step by step
wait the things to complete and then
testing happen then measuring the
progress within the stages
is difficult so why is it difficult
measuring the progress within the stages
because the deliverables or the metrics
what are defined are defined to
measure at a milestone and at a end of
the phase to understand whether
everything is delivered as part of it
now let us look at how agile is going to
help us
to address these disadvantages mentioned
in what fall model
so what is agile the basic meaning of
agile is to move faster
be flexible respond to change etc but to
accomplish this there are a lot of
methodologies
now there is something called agile
manifesto on 12 principles of agile
which we need to understand so
following this accomplishing this can
only help us in becoming a child
so in 2001 agile was introduced
so that's where the term agile came into
picture where people start realizing
what is agile
and why should we adopt that agile
methodologies
so while it was introduced so agile
manifesto was also released
it's a set of principles used in project
management and software development
so basically there are four points which
we need to understand very correctly
very clearly
so that we can able to understand what
is agile is all about
right it enables team to deliver value
to their customers with ease
so agile team deliver work in small but
usable increments
then evaluation of the requirements
plans and results takes place
continuously
this allows teams to respond to changes
quickly now change was one of the
scenario what we were speaking about
now responding to change quickly is one
of the disadvantages what we spoke about
and here it is addressed
it is considered to address that is very
important now when we respond to change
quickly it is not that i just quickly
responded but i did not address that
problem or that scenario
it is very essential to address that
scenario as well effectively and
efficiently
so now agile is a concept right
so it has a detailed manifesto based on
which
all the agile methodologies are created
so what is this agile manifesto is all
about
so it is created it was created during
february 2001
so which details out the values and
principles of agile processes
which says there are some values which
is mentioned in the left
which has more weightage compared to the
one which is in the right
now when we say this for example let us
take let us go one by one
individuals and interactions over
process and tools
so are we saying we don't value the
process and tools
that is not the case now let us look at
what were the typical
issues or challenges anyone would have
expressed regarding the processes
so delay may be bureaucracy and
they cannot have a flexibility to move
faster so basically delays because of
the approval which is not happening
because of the processes
now how do we address this so can i
eliminate the process itself
answer is no because in the absence of
tools and processes
none of the things which we can do
easily can exist
so it should be there process and tool
should be there the way it should be
defined it should also ensure there is
individuals and interactions encouraged
to have their individuals
and interactions while having the
process and tools so next is working
products or comprehensive documentation
so when we say comprehensive
documentation as i mentioned in the
waterfall methodology during the
requirement gathering during designing
there is a
detailed documentation which is made so
which take lot of efforts in creating
those
now while delivering the challenge what
anyone was faced was
the change which is coming up and making
changes to these documentations which is
an additional effort
now if we have a working products if i
have a bigger product
in that a module of that i keep creating
every
small small modules of it and start
integrating to the base model
now i will only focus on the
documentation for that particular model
working piece which i am going to create
in the next iterations
then my documentation changes are less
and also the way i'm making the
documentation is initially i would have
a full skeleton
of the entire product which i am going
to create the roadmap
and upon that i am going to making the
detailed documentation for that only for
that working piece rather than the full
product itself
then these working piece documentation
which i am going to create as i create
the working pieces i am also getting the
feedback
because i am doing the interactions with
the users the consumers the end users
so i get the feedback i keep making the
changes quickly and then documentation
will become accordingly
the small pieces of documentation which
happens with those small small small
working models which are created
and those are consolidated over a period
of time by the time the product
ends you have a comprehensive
documentation the project hands you have
a comprehensive documentation
so it saves lot of time so documentation
is important
but the way we accomplish the
documentation is one by one not in one
go
next is customer collaboration or
contract negotiation
so any engagement or any relationship or
any business can it happen in the
absence of contract
answer is no there should be a contract
now how this contract should be when we
want to follow an agile it should allow
the customer collaboration
why are we collaborating to understand
what is required
to understand what customer needs is
fulfilled
right so now this requires a lot of
flexibility in the contract itself
so that commercial is one area which
gets impacted and there should be
guidelines for that also in the contract
so that during the collaboration during
the change during the effort being put
customer is also informed what is the
change which is going to happen in terms
of commercial
as well as time and everything so that
it is documented in the contract so
there is no
confusion responding to change or
following a plan
now we cannot have a rigid plan as we
were speaking about waterfall
methodology so that we need to go like
this only
so based on the scenarios changes so we
require to change your directions and
move faster so responding to change
requires a specific flexibility which is
required in the plan
so that you i don't have a plan which is
very rigid and that
provides some flexibility that's how i
can able to create my plan so that
i can able to move or respond to that
specific scenarios which are
changing so this is called agile
manifesto
and this agile manifesto has 12
principles
associated with this now keeping this
agile manifest on 12 principles
all the agile methodologies have created
their own approaches and framework
now let us look at what are those 12
principles the agile principles
so agile principles so here are some of
principles that need to be followed to
make a processes
agile so first principle is about
customer satisfaction
so one need to satisfy the customer
through early and quick delivery of the
product
now someone who is hungry if you give
them a water
or a food immediately a piece of bread
at least there is some satisfaction
there is some realization as i got it
what i need
so energy is back so it is very much
required to ensure seeing things in a
customer perspective
and customer is satisfied so customer
satisfaction is not a result of the
survey what i do
it's about how i deal with the consumer
what is that impact the perceptions i'm
building with the consumer
and what do i know about my customer do
i really understand the pulse of my
customer
how associated am i how close am i how
am i collaborating with the customer
that will help you to understand how
satisfied your customer is
it is very essential to consider
customer satisfaction and the
second principle would be welcome change
so changing needs need to be addressed
even late in the
development process so change can happen
anytime
now these changes should not become a
challenge so there should be a
flexibility
in your design itself which will bring
in so that is the reason i think when
you move faster
so it doesn't mean that you eliminate or
you
just keep introducing the defects and
move faster no that is not allowed
so whenever there is a change in the
feature whenever there is a change to
some
specific product functionality
accommodating that should become easier
whatever the methodology i follow
that should help me in terms of
accommodating so i should be welcoming
changes it's okay for me to have the
change
so that is not a challenge anymore for
me so principle three
deliver frequently so ensure software is
delivered frequently focusing on
shorter time scales as i was mentioning
while discussing the manifesto point
like i keep creating a smaller piece of
product modules
so that i keep putting into the base
model and integrating those and
ultimately once all the features
functionalities are integrated
we have a product with all the features
and functionality
so this needs to happen more frequently
so the release of those
working p should happen more frequently
more repeatedly
so that the customer is seeing those
working piece and experiencing
and giving their feedbacks so quick
changes to those working piece making
that will become
easier then work together so when i
work together it is very essential that
developers and business individuals
need to work together through the course
of project which means
involvement of customers involvement of
suppliers involvement of your own
team everyone should work together each
one should understand
each other's perspective view if there
is no proper understanding about
each other's perspective view it is
quite obvious what was
expected what was delivered would not
match
so there should be correct understanding
to have that correct understanding one
should work together
collaborate so they should speak express
which is very important so feedback has
to be given by consumers
regularly similarly the organization
who's doing the project should also keep
giving the feedbacks to the suppliers to
make necessary changes
and once it works together in a uni zone
i think that would help in terms of
bringing out the results the way it is
required that would help customer to
get the value motivated team so projects
need to
build around motivated individuals and
they must be trusted to get the job done
means when will the team get motivated
when the work what they are doing
is acknowledged when the work what they
are doing the results are seen
experienced and then feedback is given
there is an opportunity for learning and
contribution
their contribution is acknowledged only
then team is motivated
when there is a motivated team when team
feels there is someone
with whom they can look up to it is
quite obvious
team will also come up with certain set
of innovation in their mind
giving their feedback as well involving
themselves in terms of getting the
results what is required
so it is always essential to ensure the
team which is involved
in creating the products is always
motivated so i think when we say team
the conflict also come across
there may be a clash between the various
different thoughts and preferences
so one cannot just shy away being a
manager one cannot shy away from it
he or she should involve sit with the
team resolve those put things in the
right direction so right lead
interpersonal skills are very important
here
next face-to-face interactions so which
helps in terms of
most efficient means of communication
which helps in terms of giving a proper
clarity in terms of what is required
so that i sent an email i expect the
person to do it that is not the case
what we are discussing about
so more and more interactions which
should happen face to face so that each
other understand what requires to be
done
and there is a quick feedback which can
happen when that particular interactions
conversation which keeps happening
so one can understand other perspective
view as well
then working software so it is a
primarily the deliverable which you're
speaking about which has to
come regularly so more and more working
piece as it comes
customer can give feedback based on
their experience on this working piece
instead of just imagining something and
then giving the feedback
so it should not look like an hypothesis
or something which is in the dreamland
so i told something
the person would heard visualize
something else it should not end up that
way
instead of that give the working piece
expect the consumer the user to give the
feedback
so that it helps in terms of creating
that particular product ultimately which
is
usable and which is going to create
value to the consumers
so next is constant pace so agile
process promotes sustainable development
so
it should not i did it and i sleep i did
it and then i'm waiting for something
else
no there should be frequent deliverables
which is happening so there should be
constant
moment from left to right from beginning
to end so that
the deliverables which are expected
keeps happening
so that consumers or users are realizing
the value of it
so it should be constant pace the
velocity the speed which needs to be
adopted then good design agility can be
improved by focusing on technical
excellence and good design
so when we say technical excellence and
good design it is very essential to
understand
insight towards what is that product
being delivered
insight towards what is the technology
being used insight towards the processes
the capabilities skills so all this
comes together
when people sit together and focus on
creating that product or services
so they are putting the effort towards
designing it appropriately so that that
will fit for purpose
so since things are moved step by step
in terms of creating a working piece
the detailed designing of that small
working piece would happen which can
happen quicker as well
and since these are going and fitting
into the architecture which is basically
open
architecture kind of scenarios what
you're speaking about so all those
modules what you create you keep
plugging into it
so that you were designing that small
piece which is quicker so instead of
designing the entire system as a whole
in detail you're just creating the small
null pieces and fitting into that
architecture which is open so pluggable
so that
gives flexibility as well and changes to
the design will become easier if it's
not working
and the agility helps in accomplishing
that
simplicity the amount of work that's not
being done needs to be minimized
meaning when we say simplicity doesn't
mean less
right so the appropriate number of tasks
the minimum number of tasks it needs to
be done
and mostly i think all adding activities
and processes would be removed
it has to be removed so the more
optimized more simpler in terms of
handling things is always good
so that only those what is required to
be done are done so it is very clearly
visible
and there will be clarity
self-organization
so when we say self-organized teams who
is
not capable of everything but when you
look at a team has a whole each one has
different different skills many skills
not one or two skills many skills which
they are complementing to each other
so they come together they discus
together they focus on the architectures
requirements and design
and address it together so team is also
owning the ownership is one thing when
it comes to picture when we say
team so here since tim is actually
taking up that ownership
and organizing themselves to accomplish
the results the products what is
required
so then obviously the results will
happen the way it is needed
and they will become accountable as a
team so they cannot have a blaming
scenario where because of one or two
members it is happening they should
collaborate better they should be
self-organizing what should happen
so next is reflect and adjust
so when are we going to reflect reflect
upon what is that happening learn
understand keep learning it having a
reflection to that what is happening
means responding to that so that
improvement can happen
quicker effectiveness can be improved by
the team regularly reflecting on it
so team is also understanding team is
also having that accountability to
ensure that necessary adjustments
necessary actions are taken to make
those changes and corrections quickly
so these are about 12 principles so
which supports which
helps that accomplishment of manifesto
points
the four manifesto points what is
mentioned so keeping these
four manifesto points for values which
is mentioned in manifesto and then
12 principles so keeping these in mind
any agile methodologies have their own
approaches
and they accomplish all of this so
further let us look at some of the
advantages what would be there when
following agile so we looked at the
disadvantages what we have when we
follow waterfall
so did we overcome those the
disadvantages what we had in
waterfall did we overcome that using
agile so what are the advantages of
agile
so agile is helpful in terms of
handling large amounts of interactions
between client and project team
because it is throwing lights on it so
importance of interactions the
importance of
collaboration the what is that
self-organized teams
it is spoken more and more then improve
transparency to claims in every phase of
the project how this transparency
because customer is seeing those
products
the products with features and
functionalities are seen they're
experiencing it and based on that
they're giving the feedback
there is nothing something hidden like
when i go with waterfall
till the end of the project customer
don't know what is going to come out
as a whole but here since the working
piece is given regularly
customer is seeing it the users are
using it and giving their feedback so
interactions increased so visibility
towards what we are creating results is
more
right then the delivery of the output is
predictable and can sometime be earlier
than
expected because we know what is being
delivered
more and more clarity users are
obtaining at the same time the team
which is creating is obtaining
because of it the pulse of the customer
the directions are clear
accommodating changes which was the
challenges in it was a big challenge in
waterfall methodology
has become easier here so then the cost
of the project are predictable
and follow a rigid schedule so it is
very easy to handle the schedules
because
more and more you interact and more
iterations are in
creation of small small working piece of
a product working model of the product
so now as you progress in that you
understood the environment better you
understood the clients better the
customers better
the expectation better and moving faster
so that will become easier for you now
you have become predictable you can
predict easily what is that
going to happen ultimately so more and
more visibility you start getting
so handling things will become easier
so then it allows for changes to refine
and reprioritize the product backlog
so when i say product backlog we need to
understand the various different user
stories what is written to deliver
so that is a list of deliverables
product backlog what are there
since we already know what other things
needs to be created so this helps in
terms of prioritizing those
changing the priorities based on the
change scenario
and then taking the pace taking the
speed accordingly
the client can provide the priority of
features allowing the team to ensure
maximum project value so since it is
visible what are the user stories what
are the effects written
what is that order priorities order of
priority what we are kept
now the change scenario obviously tells
us do we really need to change this
priority of which feature has to be done
first so that will become easier because
you have the list
only changing that order in the list and
then going forward accordingly
integration is not an issue because we
have the base model which can integrate
all of this together with no issues
now then by focusing on needs of the
users the team can deliver value to the
customers
so users are involved more often so user
pulse is understood what user requires
is clearly understood
so delivering that value to the customer
will become more easier
and simpler so then project is broken
into smaller units
with high quality development testing
and collaboration because you have the
flexibility
so since you have better visibility you
can able to do this
and you move one by one iteration by
iterations
you progress further so those were the
advantages of
adopting agile now keeping that agile
manifesto on 12 principles of manifesto
so what are the types of typical agile
methodologies would come across
so there are few which we are going to
look at as part of it which we need to
know
so this agile methodologies definitely
considers
the agile manifesto points and then they
demonstrate it
in their own way now agile methodologies
perspective let us go one by one
so some of them to look at the first one
is
xp that is extreme programming so this
is the framework that enables
teams to create high quality software
and improves their quality of life
so it enables software development with
appropriate engineering practices
so and then when is it applicable so it
is applicable to the scenario where
changing
software requirements to handle risks
caused due to new technology
while working with a small extended
development team
to use technology to allow automated
unit and functional tests
so that is about extreme programming so
next let us look at
kanban so kanban is a methodology which
is used
to design manage and improve the flow of
system
it is actually called as pull system so
visual system
so everything which is actually put on a
board and it is visible to everyone
what work need to be done what is in
progress who has to do it is very
clearly visible
so organizations can visualize their
flow of work and the limiting their work
in progress so what is limiting what is
stopping is clearly visible
so generally if i look at whenever i'll
just take a scenario of
a meeting and minutes of meeting which
always discuss about it
now when there is a minutes of meeting
shared with many
people who have participated in the
meeting there are certain action items
given to them
for example now these action items i
will have a target date to complete and
accordingly
those needs to be closed now when the
next meeting happens
when you look at the action item status
majority of them are not addressed
what could be the reason is that people
are not sensitive about answering or
addressing those so more than that the
prioritization changes
so one important thing we need to
understand how kanban works here is
it is a visual system compared to that
minutes of meeting which is not visible
to us always
the kanban board is visible to us always
so
one which is visible to us always makes
us
put a conscious effort to close it
because our name is indicated on the
board
the work need to be completed is
mentioned against our name
then we need to take it up and then
close it so it pushes it
it will put a conscious effort because
it is visible and
i cannot build any storage telling that
why i did not do why did i not consider
this as a priority rather than
consider something else as a priority so
this kanban straight up addresses it
and then it's also called as pull system
because people pull the work from it and
then
complete right so where is this
applicable
it can be used in situations where work
arrives in an
unpredictable fashion so that means it
gives a lot of flexibility in terms of
adopting to the changes which are
happening the dynamics environment
so it is also used to deploy work
immediately without waiting for other
work items
so since it is visible i think things
can go smoother
easier so that people are owning it
rather than just disowning it
so now let us look at lean so when we
say lean it is very important for us to
understand
that value is always in customer
perspective
and elimination of waste these are the
two things mainly spoken about
so lean is a set of tools and principles
that aims to identify and remove
waste to increase the speed of process
development
it focuses on maximizing the value to
the client ensuring
waste is minimized so when you look at
visualize
a processes process interfaces and the
flow
so the interface certain way so unless
the output of
one process or procedure is getting into
an another process
so that flow should be smoother like
many pipes connected together and water
is flowing
so let us assume series of pipes which
is of around
one feet in terms of diameter of each of
the pipes
water is flowing in between if you have
a pipe which is off half a feet
now what happens to the downstream after
that half feet
pipe the entire capacity in the
downstream even though it has one feet
diameter
pipe it leads to the waste under
utilized capacity because this has
become
bottleneck now such bottlenecks such
the one which contributes to the waste
has to be eliminated
that is very important so value should
be seen in the consumer perspective
and that value would happen only through
the series value streams
then in this value stream the
identification of the constraints and
bottlenecks
and elimination of waste now what are
the contributors of waste
so waiting time more often changing
things
moving from one place to another place
allowing defects to flow which leads
towards a rework
so all this likewise many things which
actually end up in
giving the ways so one has to visualize
understand realize
what are those non-valuing activities
and eliminating those
is very important right so now when is
it applicable
lean principles apply to any sector
where there is waste of
any form so it can be applied easily so
one is to
know that so it should effort which
needs to be put with the objective to
accomplish
so your ability to move faster your
ability to
create that product which is more
efficient so
only you can achieve it the effective
results can happen
only when there is a lesser delays or
lesser waste
non-valuing activities that needs to be
understood and eliminate those
so next one of the popular methodology
would be scrum
so scrum is a framework that is used by
teams to establish
a hypothesis trying it out reflect on
the experience and adjust
it is used to enable teams to
incorporate practices from other
frameworks depending on the team's
requirement
it's a simple framework which speaks
about a product owner
a scrum master a self-organizing team
so some of the terminologies what it
uses is sprint
daily scrum product backlog sprint
backlog
so it's very essential to understand
this framework simpler and able to adopt
it is also very easy
when is it applicable it is used when
cross-functional teams are working on
product development
when work is split into more than one
two to four week iterations
so these iterations are called as
sprints small
boxed iterations so this will also help
in terms of
accomplishing the results provides that
flexibility
and able to move faster then crystal
so crystal is an approach to the
software development
that focuses on people and their
interactions
rather than tools and processes it is
aimed to streamline processes
and improve optimization it works on
principle that
projects are unique and dynamic
each requiring its specific methods so
where is it applicable
it focuses on strengthening teams
communication
it also focuses on continuous
integration
active user involvement and configurable
processes
so these are the few agile methodologies
which are there which are more popular
more heard however we can come across
many other methodologies like safe agile
which is a scaled scenario for more
complex projects
so likewise we have many methodologies
which organizations adopt
and these are few for us to understand
as part of this tutorial
we are going to understand the basic
understanding requirements
of scrum the agile methodology
so let us look at the problem scenario
what was there in the absence of
adoption of agile in any given
environment so in the given scenario
there is a problem expressed
so we have a problem our consumer
doesn't like our product
we will have to make changes immediately
so now as usual any manager would
respond
the manager says make the changes so
because
it's always the changes or anything what
we deliver
is in the consumer's interest so keeping
consumers interest in mind the value it
needs to be created for customers
any changes required to be done in any
of our projects
involving that consumers and customer we
may require to do the change
so but what is the problem here to do
the change so we can't
we already have started work on last
batch
the waterfall model we follow doesn't
let changes to
be made midway through the process so is
it mean the waterfall model never allows
the changes to happen
that is not true hundred percent
waterfall model
allows us to make changes but it doesn't
allows us to make the changes
quickly so whenever there is a change it
requires lot of effort
it requires changes in documentation it
asks for the changes in
various different implementations which
has already done which is executed
already
and then lot of efforts are involved
which is time consuming
and also it involves more cost now how
do we make the change which is required
to the customer
and at the same time we don't have any
specific additional effort which are
required
so these efforts whatever is being put
is acceptable to both the parties both
the stakeholders that is
the project organization as well as the
customer
so how do you make it happen quickly as
well that is very important for us
so we should have used the agile
methodologies so meaning
agile methodology helps us to do this so
one of the
agile methodologies which we are going
to look at as part of this tutorial is
scrum
so let us see how scrum is going to help
the scenario so scenario of
changes which are coming up more
frequently right
right before that let us understand what
is the meaning of
agile what is the meaning of agile what
it
means and why should we adopt agile
so agile means moving faster
being flexible responding to the changes
now agile is a set of methods and
practices that focuses on
iterative development why iterative in
each iterations
agile methodologies helps us to create a
working piece of
the software product which will help us
to make quick corrections to those
software piece
this is not a whole product it is part
of that bigger product
so requirements and solutions are
obtained
thanks to self-organizing
cross-functional teams collaborating
so when we say cross-functional team
self-organizing
team so these are the teams which are
seven plus or minus two
the size of the team what i'm speaking
about who basically
have various different skills each of
the team members will have various
different skills
and they complement to it i think today
the devops is speaking about this
cross-functional team owning everything
as a single team some of the
organizations
has already demonstrated their devops
capabilities by having this approach
like having self-organizing and
cross-functional team having an
accountability for the entire product
the particular piece of the product
module what they have created
so this helps in improving
accountability and also ensures
better visibility of the product what is
being created
and delivered so
further let us look at the advantages of
using agile
so what it gives to us how it helps
so now the organization who follows the
gel methodologies
so we can see that projects follow a
predefined schedule and have a
predictable cause
so schedules are seen but wherever there
is a changes required wherever these
directions need to be changed in terms
of making necessary changes to adopt to
the
required scenario the change scenario
agile helps us
it gives that flexibility so clients
have visibility of each phase of project
so it is very essential whosoever adopts
the agile methodology
the active involvement of customer has
to be ensured
so they are actively involved so
customers or clients actively involved
in the sense
they know it what is happening what they
are getting
they know they are acknowledging it by
giving the feedbacks
every now and then so that there is no
surprise to them at the end
which used to happen during waterfall
approaches
then greater interaction between project
team and the project
means there needs to be collaboration
agile emphasizes on having the
collaboration
so scrum in specific have something
called daily uh scrum where 15 minutes
meeting where entire uh scrum team
should come in
sit together self-organizing team as
well as all the
agile team has to come together express
what they have completed before the last
daily scrum meeting and what is pending
why is it pending
and what is that they are going to do
before the next meeting so all these are
expressed this will help
the team as well as the scrum master as
well as the product owner the
visibility into what is complete what
needs to be completed
and this will help project manager or
scrum master to provide the necessary
inputs better visibility to the
customers and stakeholders as well
product output is predictable and can
sometimes happen
earlier than expected so now initially
as we know so the visibility of anything
what we do
will be very less so now as we discuss
more and more as we brainstorm more and
more
the visibility into it will become more
then what would happen in future the
ability to predict
will also become easier and if this
doesn't happen only with the project
team it also happens with customers and
every stakeholders who are involved in
the
project so next
high quality development testing and
collaboration is
ensured since the project is broken down
so now each iterations each module
each piece of software which is being
created are tested regularly
feedbacks are obtained from the user as
well active involvement of user are
ensured so that they are acknowledging
it
so the what customer needs are given so
it is not that i discover something
which i did not need i i'm seeing it i
told something i'm getting something
that scenario is eliminated
then the product backlog can be refined
and reprioritized
so since we move iteration wise
depending on the change scenario
depending on the directions changes
we can keep reordering or
re-prioritizing our product backlog
what needs to be created first if have
one two three four five item i can make
it as
three four one two five so depending on
the change scenario
whenever it needs to be executed it is
bit flexible
and easy to do then teams can
maximize project value since clients can
provide
project priority so as we know the
visibility also increases
to the consumer as well as all the
stakeholders they will also express
what is that value they have seen from
this
and this will also help in making a
decision should we continue with this
project or should we not
so better visibility better decision
making better value realization
the needs of the customer can be focused
on increasing the
value delivered so as customer gives the
feedback as that visibility increases
then a customer is getting that value
and then
expressing what is the changes what is
that additionally they may required here
how can make it better so these
interactions can happen
so customer can be focused on increasing
the value delivery
so in fact i think earlier we used to
speak about time to market
today we're speaking about time to value
which means how quickly uh the consumers
the users or customers
realizes the value is that benefit
realized
so that's what the more and more
discussion which is happening
which requires closer collaboration with
consumers and
their feedbacks their experiences with
the products or services which are being
used by them
it is very essential to understand so
then various different methodologies
what we have in agile
we can speak about scrum kanban extreme
programming that is xp
lean methodologies the crystal so now
in this video tutorial we are actually
focusing on scrum
so let us understand what is this scrum
is all about
right so before we go and understand
what is the scrum itself so let us look
at the history of scrum where it started
how it started
so right down the line during 1986
the name scrum is first introduced by
the management experts
yukujiro nanaka and hirotakat kuchi
so japanese so now this
terminology introduced but later in 1995
jeff sutherland and ken schubert
creates the early version of what would
become the agile methodologies
so now earlier 1995 so need for agile
was
sensed and was spoken about i mean why
do we need a gel methodologies in future
what would be the future organization
which would look like so that would
trigger
in terms of what kind of approaches we
may require to have
so further 2001 the agile alliance is
founded
and first look on scrum the agile
software development with scrum is
published
so then further down the line 2002 the
scrum alliance is founded by
weber and certifications are added
then later 2006 the scrum link is
created
the certified scrum courses are taught
so people started getting certified on
scrum then later 2009 scrum.org is
created
which offers the professionals scrum
series of certifications
then 2010 the first scrum guide is
published so which made available to
everyone
so from then i think the more and more
people start adopting
scrum methodologies now interesting part
is the journey started from
1980s till 2010 various changes which
has happened to this particular
methodology but one thing we should keep
in mind is
same 20 years back or 15 20 years back
if we go
the need for a jail was not seen so it
was spoken but need for a gel was not
spoken much
but today we are speaking about it more
and more the reason is
i think the change in the market
condition the increase in the
competition
the need of responding to the change
which is asked by the
consumers of the market variations has
become more and more
important for organizations and service
providers if they don't respond to the
change
they may lose out in the competition so
their survival is at stake so it is very
essential for them to understand this
dynamics
and respond to those scenarios quickly
so that's where the adoption of agile
the benefit of adopting a jail were
realized
and scrum become popular so what is
scrum
so let us look at that so now scrum is a
framework that
enables teams to work together
means collaboration is very important
while we become agile
so with scrum team one can look
i mean see and experience so learning
from experiences happens
so those are captured self-organized
working on problems so they work
together they discuss
brainstorm reflect on their victories
means
any achievements has to be celebrated
acknowledged
quick queens recognized and their losses
to improve
so wherever the things doesn't go good
necessary corrections has to be done
i think scrum approach would help in
terms of doing it quicker
better then some of the benefits using
scrum would look like steam can provide
project deliverables and in an efficient
manner
so in time we are completing all the
features and functionality so the the
entire model
the methodology what is there which
helps in accomplishing those
then further time and money are used
efficiently
so time is very important giving results
in the
mentioned schedule is very important
ensuring results are coming up
effectively is
important efficiently the performance of
that products
now since we are creating those small
piece
working piece in every iterations so
that experience of using that would also
be there and quick feedbacks will come
back
so that time and money is saved and we
are doing in
time so projects are divided into
smaller units called sprint so the
iterations
what are speaking about the quick
iterations of activities which happens
uh during the
adoption of scrum when organization
adopt describe methodology
so it is called a sprint it's a time box
iterations which will have
a set of subset of product backlog taken
as a sprint backlog
and those users stories and epics are
delivered as part of that
sprint and then those are reviewed on a
daily basis as part of daily scrum
meeting and also
we have other meetings which will happen
when we go and look at
methodology how this happens i think
we'll get better visibility
work best for fast moving projects now
whenever we need to respond quickly
whenever we want to move faster now
remember when we say moving faster means
it doesn't mean that we can allow any
defects to happen
we can ignore something we cannot do
that we need to ensure everything is
taken care
at the same time all those results what
are created
has to be acknowledged right confirmed
yes it is defect free
so all those which is supposed to be
addressed are taken care and things are
moving faster and better and the results
are according to
what was actually expressed as a
requirement it is fulfilling those
then scrum meetings provide the team
great visibility
since there is a daily scrum meeting
which keeps happening people speaks
about
what they have done from the previous
daily scram what is that they have
accepted they will complete and what is
complete
is everything is complete or something
is pending if it is pending
why is that pending and what is that you
are going to do
further before the next daily scrum
meeting so these are discussed
understood so that there is a quick 15
minutes meeting which gives the insight
and further wherever there is a
dependency deviations which occurs
further maybe scrum master sit with them
separately to understand that in detail
so daily scrum meetings give the quick
insights
so that it increases the visibility what
is happening on ground
constantly involves feedback from
clients and customers
as i mentioned earlier while discussing
about agile active involvement of a
customer is very essential
so customers should give the feedbacks
whenever that working piece of the
application or a product is given
so only then whether the product or that
module what is created is
having that features and functionality
which helps in providing necessary
requirement fulfillment is that
happening or not
then making changes based on feedback
are very easy
because everyone is informed and they
are aware of
what is being changed and what needs to
be changed
then individual efforts of the team
members are given focus
yes individual efforts is essential at
the same time
each team member cross skills we call it
a self-organizing team as i was
mentioning earlier
so each team member will have different
different skills different different
capabilities
and also cross-skilling within the team
is encouraged so that
the ownership on individuals
deliverables and
team as a whole working together to
deliver some features functionality
can also be accomplished right
then scrum team involves product owner
scrum master and then scrum team
so each of these are different roles
having their own objectives to
accomplish with the specific directions
and each of this cannot be merged like
for example
the roles and responsibilities of
product owner cannot be
given to single individual who is a
scrum master
so both the roles cannot be given a
single individual because it conflicts
the objectives of both the rules
so thinking about putting this one of
the team member becoming scrum master
product owner
thinking in that angle is also something
which is which will not
work which will not give the required
results so now what are these roles what
are the responsibilities
where is the focus of each of the roles
so let us discuss on that
now when it comes to product owner so
the product owner is primarily
responsible for
maximizing the roi by determining the
product features
prioritizing it into a list what needs
to be focused on for the next print and
constantly reprioritizing
and refining it so the key points what
we need to see here is
so one is determining the product
features
maximizing the roi the second one and
then
re-prioritizing and refining the product
backlog
now why is that needs to be done so
maximizing roi in the sense obviously
product owner should closely work with
the business
and have an insight towards what is that
business
require what is that customer require
how it helps customer to accomplish that
result so that it helps the justifying
that investment what they're doing
with the products features and
functionalities then
uh speaking about reprioritizing and
refining it
it depends on what features needs to be
delivered in what order
so there is already an order which is
defined so
based on the change scenario you can
reorder it
and product owner has that ownership and
responsibility so
the entire focus is on ensuring the
right product backlog
prioritizing it and also adding that
user stories and epics into
product backlog depending on what makes
sense to the business
so the scrum master the next role helps
teams learn and apply scrum to obtain
business value
means scrum master closely works with
the team
so he or she helps remove impediments
what is impediments
something which stops to move forward
something which doesn't allow
to deliver things the way it is required
something which stops
right so that needs to be eliminated
that needs to be understood what are the
impediments
so when we say impediments what are the
impediments we can think of
the skills and capabilities of the team
that is one thing
maybe the testing environment may be a
process
so anything comes as a bottleneck or
impediments which stops things to move
smoothly forward
so scrum master should work on it
identify that and support team or guide
team to overcome those so protects them
from interfaces that helps the team to
adopt
agile practices so encouraging team to
adopt agile practices
and ensuring they demonstrate it and
provides the required value as its
move forwards so since scrum master
focuses
one side in terms of making scrum team
to work whereas product owner is looking
at the entire product backlog
and working more closely with the
business so they need to have a good
handshake
to ensure things go well but these two
roles cannot be merged
because since it has a two different
angles and two different dynamics
so spending time accomplishing both the
things may become very challenging
and conflicting and the prioritizing
will also be difficult
then scrum team is a collection of all
the individuals who work together to
deliver the requirements of the
stakeholders
so self-organizing team what i was
mentioning what we were discussing
earlier
so these teams comes together each of
the team member will have various
different capabilities
so they contribute at the individual
level and as a
team has a whole complement or
contribute towards ultimate
output and outcome and value what they
need to create
and this team should have a clear
understanding about
the deliverable what is being done so is
that deliverable what features and
functionality what they're thinking
is that going to create that value
ultimately what
is need to be achieved the requirements
fulfillment which is which needs to be
happen to the customers
so they need to have that understanding
the direction should be clear to the
team
so there are certain artifacts to look
at when it comes to scrum
so let us look at that so now we speak
about
the artifacts which are the components
of the scrum process
that can improve transparency and
understanding of the work
so there are three artifacts mainly
which we call it as a
product backlog sprint backlog
then product increment so let us see
what is this one by one
so when i say product backlog so it
consists of
list of new features changes
to be made to existing features the bug
fixes
changes to the infrastructure and
several other activities
that the team needs to deliver to ensure
a particular outcome
so this list show product backlogs
becomes with
required features and functionalities
what needs to be delivered so
the prioritization of this has to happen
in what order what needs to be delivered
so the product backlog is the full list
which needs to be delivered as part of
this project and as the project
progresses
a lot of new backlog item will be added
to the product backlog
as the dynamics of the particular
scenarios keeps changing so
keeps adding reprioritizing additional
items to the backlogs are
added depending on what are those
dynamics
so further looking at a sprint backlog
so
sprint refers to that short period of
iterations
right so which team aims to get a given
amount of work done
so it helps teams deliver working
software in a frequent manner
so sprint could be between one to four
weeks long depending on
what is that deliverable is so sprint
backlog is a subset of product backlogs
so that prioritized item what is taken
into sprint which is a time boxed
iterations
the sprint backlog contains the task the
team aims to complete to satisfy the
sprint goal so what is that sprint goal
so each of those iterations the time box
iterations
will have a specific objective to
accomplish so the sprint goal is the
objective decided for the sprint as an
outcome of negotiation between the
product owner and the team
so what can be delivered how long it
takes to deliver
so when it has to be delivered the
target may be given by product owner but
is it possible feasible to complete it
there is some negotiation which happens
there
so they decide they agree yes we can do
it we cannot do it
if at all we can do it what is that it
takes in terms of effort time and cost
everything is decided discussed so that
objective of that particular iterations
is
agreed upon so once it is agreed i think
a team should first identify the tasks
from the product backlog that need to be
delivered to achieve the goal
so these stars are then added to spread
backlog so there should be an agreement
between both
and once it is added once it is agreed
as part of that sprint
the deliverable the output of the sprint
would be the one which needs to be
completed as part of it the objective is
the goal the results it's a specific
working
software then product increment
so this refers to the combination of all
product backlog
tasks completed in the sprint and the
value of the increment of
previous sprints now when we speak about
lean
lean speaks about elimination of waste
it speaks about value streams
now in each of these prints as we have a
working software being delivered
now each of these piece should keep
complementing to the what is
the one which is already delivered and
what is being delivered in future
so keeping that in mind every
deliverable will be
implemented or configured in such a way
that there is no
specific bottlenecks there is no
specific constraints which arises
so this needs to be kept in mind which
requires the entire visibility into what
is that ultimate
objective we are going to accomplish so
in this product increment
all those combination of the product
backlogs task which is being done
should keep this in mind team should be
very clear about it so i
in the first sprint i delivered
something in the spring two i delivered
something but i cannot integrate them
they cannot work together
it will lead into the further issues and
then complications that should not
happen
so when we say agile it's about moving
faster fine
so responding to change fine but that
should not lead towards further
complexity it should make things
simpler smoother so scrum is stressing
on that part
so an increment refers to inspectable
usable work done at the end of the
sprint it represents a step towards
overall goal or vision of the project as
i was
mentioning then the outcome should be in
usable condition
even if the product owner doesn't decide
to release it
so it should be in usable condition so
two things we speak about so one is uh
release other one is deployment now
people usually get confused between
release and deployment
so release about this part what we're
speaking about product
is usable so it is released product is
usable
but only after deployment user will have
an access to use it
so that is the difference release makes
that product usable
whereas deployment makes it available to
the user to use
so this difference people should know so
release doesn't mean that
it is already available for user to use
so this
understanding of the difference should
also be there so that one can understand
what it means by release as well
and what it means by deployment that's
why when we speak about devos we keep
speaking about
cicd in cicd we speak about continuous
integration
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment so in continuous delivery
speaking about release basically
so once it is released it becomes usable
so once it is
deployed it is available for user to
use and that's about the scrum artifacts
now let us look at scrum framework how
that scrum
framework looks like in entirety so what
are the components comes into picture
already we spoke about the
scrum approach itself what it is now we
spoke about
understanding artifacts then we spoke
about roles in scrum
the activities for each of the roles we
understood now where do we see all of
this when we look at a scrum framework
so that picture let us see
so when we say scrum framework already
we spoke about the product backlog
we can see that it is in the left side
in the beginning
we have a sprint planning so we spoke
about sprint the time box iterations
and from the product backlog the items
which is moving towards
sprint to a specific sprint what needs
to be delivered which become
sprint backlog now the backlog items are
taken and scrum team work on it
and does this daily scrum meeting and
once the deliverables of that particular
sprint happens then there is a review on
it
then the increment is delivered and at
the same time that retrospective what
was planned versus what is delivered
that is
checked if you look at from sprint
review so you have a retrospective to
check
what is planned versus what is being
delivered at the same time the review
points will come and
get updated to product backlog as well
to the product owner so product owner
should be aware what is delivered what
is pending to be delivered
and that increment is further delivered
so these increments what is delivered to
production
what is deployed in the production
should have values
that integration which happens both all
the increments coming together to
provide that
fulfillment of the requirement as well
as creating that value
what is required so product backlog is
the first step of scrum framework
is a set of list of tasks to have
successfully achieve the
goals of the stakeholders we discuss
that while discussing on product backlog
so further sprint planning happens where
the team determines the tasks from the
product catalog
they will work on and aim to deliver
during the
sprint now this is negotiated understood
agreed and then most towards sprint to
get delivered
then sprint backlog are the tasks
discussed during the sprint planning
means the previous step and also do the
script planning and then add it to the
sprint backlog once it goes to the
sprint backlog as part of the time
boxed iteration sprint the deliverables
should happen
now scrum team the scrum team which is
actually self-organizing team as we
mentioned
maybe five to ten nine members of team
working on the task in the
sprint backlog and they will also have a
daily scrums
where the team also discusses for 15
minutes
on the events where the team member
synchronizes activities and plan what
they aim to achieve in next
24 hours what is accomplished against
what is discussed in
previous daily scrum and then
if at all any further discussions need
to be done in the correction of those
that can be taken as a separate meeting
not as part of the daily scrum
so generally daily scrub meeting would
be 15 minutes it should not go
more than that it's an indicative time
so quicker updates to understand what is
happening
then uh the sprint review happens where
once the sprint is complete so sprint
review happens
which involves the team the scrum master
and product owner and stakeholders to
understand
what is being agreed upon and what is
being delivered or reviewed
is that fulfilled in the entirety that
is discussed
and then during this meeting the team
shows what they accomplish during the
sprint
it allows time to ask questions make
observations
give feedback and provide suggestions
right
then the product owner also presents the
product backlogs top to the stakeholders
to get feedback for upcoming sprints and
about things related to the backlog
now this one sprint is complete for the
next print what should be the
prioritization
so the product owner has to speak with
the stakeholders so that
there is a good understanding good
handshake that what needs to be
delivered
and what is the priority in the given
list
then sprint retrospective happens so
after this print review
sprint retrospective happens so during
this meeting
what went well like past mistakes
potential issues
what are the new ways to handle them
which are required to be
done correctly in the next iterations or
next prints needs to be identified
data from found from here are
incorporated when planning the
new sprint so it works like a lessons
learnt what went well
what did not go well what is that we did
for those what did not go well
so what is that learning we have in
these iterations so how can we
ensure that in the upcoming iterations
the same mistakes are will not repeat
so those can be discussed documented
and then consider while moving to the
next sprint
then the increment is a workable output
which is given to the stakeholders
so this is where the user actually sees
their workable piece working item
and then they give necessary feedback as
well on the particular
application piece or software piece
then there is something called scrum
board which is used during this flow
of scrum right from product backlash to
the creation of that increment
so let us look at what is a scrum board
which is used during the scrum practice
so scrum board is a physical or virtual
tool that helps team to visualize
items in the sprint backlog so it helps
in tracking what is being delivered
what is in progress and what needs to be
delivered further
so it shows all action items during the
daily scrum
helping keeping the team focused on
tasks that need to be completion
and the priorities of those the scrum
board is
usually present in a place that's
accessible to all team members it is a
visual board right
and can be physical white board and
stickers or virtual software tools which
can be used and displayed on the
screen so the scrum board is divided
into different slots like to do
in progress and done so when new sprints
are started the existing board is reset
and new scrum board is created so since
it is visual system i think it is taking
the thought from kanban
so visual system always works effective
because
the moment i know i see something is
put against my name that i need to
complete this it's quite obvious to me
that i will put efforts to complete it
so it's a conscious effort what i will
put
it works on my consciousness so
something which is not visible to me
it is that out of sight is out of mind
so i will not
work on it so i may there is a tendency
to forget
so if i see it regularly if i have that
feeling
or that vibes which comes to every
individual set someone is
everyone is having a visibility to it
something is pending against me
so i'm answerable that consciously that
comes to the mind and people start
working on it and closing of that will
happen quickly
so everything is visible there is
nothing hidden
so look at the scenario so when once it
is explained i think
it's okay even though we messed up this
time we'll incorporate scrum into our
products
i am sure we will do a good job next
time but
keep in mind whenever change comes it
doesn't mean that i need to go and
do crumb practice never get into that
decision
understand what is the nature of change
what is that speed
how quickly you may require to do the
change and
what is the impact of the change how
often this change
is may come up you may know this from
the lessons learned with the
adopted practice and methodologies and
then decide is the existing model or
existing practice whatever we are doing
is it okay
or should we really need to go and uh by
have a buying from the scrum and
entirely we organize ourselves to have a
scrum approach so it is always advisable
to go for a scrum approach
whenever there is a dynamics of quickly
moving from left to right from product
backlog 2
that increment what needs to be created
so accomplishing that speed
and involving the consumers regularly if
it is feasible so consumer and
stakeholders may say
they cannot involve then you becoming a
gel will not make sense because they are
not even giving the feedbacks
so active involvement of the team
the scrum master the product owner the
business
the stakeholders the consumers very very
important
if they don't involve so the
deliverables cannot happen
the wait is required so active
involvement active collaboration of
every stakeholders
are essential there should be
collaboration and communication the
effective collaboration and
communication which needs to be
happening
the product team has taken up a new
project called weather master
the team is planning to move to scrum
methodology and this is an outline of
its first scrum meeting
time box to 15 minutes rick is the scrum
master of this meeting where the team
members discuss what they did yesterday
their plans for today and the
impediments they faced
all team members are standing up
including todd who's joined the meeting
via video chat
rick holds the meeting near a scrum
board angela the product owner is absent
rick reiterates that all discussions
would be parked until after the scrum
meeting
and encourages this team to keep the
meeting short
people can chime in to resolve obstacles
hi team welcome to the daily stand-up
meeting for the product team on project
weather master we are in sprint one and
today is the second day
as we are planning to transition to
scrum methodology i hope you will find
this daily stand-up meeting helpful
in this meeting you will provide
information about what you did yesterday
what you plan to do today and what
challenges you faced
i think everyone's here let's start i
don't see angela
shouldn't she be here i did add angela
as an optional attendee to this meeting
and since she hasn't showed up we don't
have to wait for her susan
scrum doesn't provide a specific yes or
no about the product owner's
participation in the daily
scrum the po's primary role is to
provide direction
and clarify requirements and priorities
since we don't always discuss those in
detail at this meeting
the po is not required to be here if the
pos want to attend they are generally in
listen only mode for the duration of the
meeting
they can use the information gathered
during the meeting for
separate offline conversations
what about todd he works from his home
office right
todd will be a part of the meeting
through video chat it is important that
we include every team member in the
meeting
hi todd how are you i'm fine thanks
am i audible yes todd team let's all
stand up for the meeting
why don't you go first aaron
yesterday i was working on creating the
mock objects to mask the database calls
from the unit tests
the difficulty with this approach is
that our server side logic is so
dependent on the metadata
that writing a true mock is a mammoth
exercise
there are decisions that are taken
during run time based on the data
some of the stored procedure calls are
also made based on the values returned
through inline queries that are also
embedded in the code
i was debugging the code until about 9
pm
but for the life of me i couldn't figure
this out
aaron could we request you to be concise
when you provide an update
if you think some of the details you
described might be interesting to others
why don't you write a wiki page on it
and share the link
so getting back to your update did you
finish the task yesterday
no it turned out to be much more complex
than i had imagined
i'll continue to work on it today and
see if i can figure out an xml structure
to mock the schema and hard code some
return values but i am
really stuck as far as the inline
queries are concerned
i know what you're talking about there
is a reason why the inline queries are
there in the code
this is mainly for performance reasons
when the overheads of making a procedure
call
based on a metadata value and then
processing sorry for the interruption
again guys
this is a really great conversation may
i suggest we write this issue in the
parking lot
i'm not sure what you mean by that rick
let me explain
what aaron just brought up is a blocking
issue team members
should bring these up during the daily
scrum so that everybody knows that one
of the team members is stuck
however the daily scrum is not
necessarily the meeting where solutions
to every obstacle can
or should be found it looks like mary
knows a thing or two about the issue
that aaron has brought up
let's jot this down as a parking lot
topic
this means the team can have offline
conversations after the daily scrum to
track it down
i'm also going to make a note that will
track the impediment erin faced
daily until it is removed you should let
me know if i can help in any way
right aaron is there anything else you
would like to say
no i am done thanks
yesterday i worked on developing the
wizards for bulk order creation
i'm almost done today i need to write
code to handle some of the exception
scenarios before i can get them over to
susan for testing
that's it for me i guess did you forget
to mention any impediments
not really an impediment at present but
i would like to mention that my computer
probably needs to be upgraded with more
ram it has been slow for the past few
weeks
okay i wrote up some scenarios to test
the bulk order wizard
i'm looking to get my hands on the code
as soon as mary is done
today i'm also hoping to complete the
company order testing that
has been pending for a while i'm okay
for the moment but i do have one
question
shouldn't we all be updating the task
board as we speak
we could it is up to you guys if you
think you want to do this during the
meeting
if you ask my opinion we should update
the board as soon as we are ready to
move the tasks
and not wait for the meeting this will
ensure that the board is always up to
date and also that we use the meeting
time
to focus on the conversations that's a
great point rick
i can't see the board very well from
here anyway so maybe we should find a
way to create an electronic version of
it too
at some point
great point todd why don't you go next
with your updates
all right hey rick would you like to
know about my work on the advertising
module first
or the integration server whatever the
team decides is fine
with me remember this is really your
meeting and i'm only here to facilitate
and ensure we get the most out of this
meeting
all right then i guess i'll start with
the integration server
i would like to inform everybody that i
managed to set up the integration server
that we can use as a sandbox to test the
code before checking it in source
control i'll send everybody a link with
some instructions and credentials
i have also started looking at the
stories for the advertising module
it looks like there are a lot of open
statements in the stories that i don't
really understand
i guess i should have been paying more
attention during the sprint planning
i really need to have a conversation
with angela about this
that is my main impediment right now i
sent her an email but haven't received a
response yet
i don't have anything new to add today
i'm almost through with setting up our
project on the freeware tool that i
downloaded yesterday
i'll show you guys a demo in the meeting
i set up later today
i'll try to chase down some of these
parking lot items anything else before
we close the meeting
alright that's it for today have a great
day
do you have a moment to chat about the
inline queries real quick
the purpose of a scrum meeting is to
keep the team members updated and
resolve any impediments
it's an ideal way to kick start the day
on a positive note
the scrum master reinforces the sense of
the self-managing team
facilitates communication between team
members
brings the team's focus back to what's
important and supports
improvement in this session we will be
talking about
agile project management and several
other things related to it
before we begin let's have a look at all
the topics we will be covering today
first we will see the basics of agile
project management
then we will check the relevance and
principles of agile project management
we will then see necessary steps to
implement agile methodology
along with that we shall also see
different frameworks involved
in the process and finally we shall see
some companies
that use agile project management so
without any further ado
let's get started with what is agile
project management agile project
management as the name suggests is a
flexible approach to building a project
in agile project management the project
is broken down into several stages of
sprints
agile does not work on the principle of
delivering the final product
at the end of the project it works on
delivering sections of a project or many
projects
the process of project management in the
case of agile is agile based
so there won't be any central control of
project manager as it was there in the
traditional way of working
before we move forward let's have a look
at the agile development cycle
agile methodologies consist of several
small cycles or sprints
at the end of each stage we get a mini
project there's a product backlog
that explains new features changes in
the existing features
and several other improvements in the
project then we have a sprint backlog
which has a list of tasks
that are to be completed during each
sprint the sprint consists of planning
designing execution testing and
deployment stages
and at the end of each sprint a mini
project is delivered
with every sprint new features are added
to the product which plays a significant
role in the overall project growth
after all the sprints and early
validation in the development
the final deliverable has a fewer
chances of failure
let's now have a look at some reasons
why industries have started
moving towards agile project management
the first reason is
high product quality when we talk about
higher product quality
we refer to the build of the product as
per stakeholders demands
testing is performed at short intervals
of time wherever needed
to ensure high quality of the product
then another reason is customer
satisfaction
whatever is done in the project is known
by the customer the deliveries don't
take longer durations
as they used to take in the case of
traditional ways the changes may be
provided by the customer in the
execution phase of the project
third reason is reduced risk since the
project is divided into sprints
so if the risk affects one sprint it
doesn't mean whole of the project will
be at risk
the process of risk analysis continues
to take place with
all the other processes another
significant reason for agile project
management is
better and faster return on investment
the project is now developed in several
sprints
and each sprint has its own version
therefore
the project becomes market ready after a
few sprints only
since the projects can now be released
with ease and in shorter duration this
helps the organization to stay ahead in
competition
with respect to other organizations
which have still not moved to agile
methodology
now we shall check the principles of
agile project management
there are 10 principles for successful
agile project management
the first principle is the satisfaction
of the customer
by delivering the project fast and with
least number of errors
the next principle refers to decreasing
the amount of time
between the phase of planning and
delivery the third principle states
that the team of managers and developers
work together
and increase the productivity of their
work the next principle states
that the changes requested by the
stakeholders can be taken into
consideration and worked upon
during the development phase as well the
fifth principle pays attention to the
factor of coordination among the team
members
then the sixth principle refers to the
process of monitoring
and tracking the progress of the project
at the end of each sprint
and making amendments wherever needed
moving on
the next principle states that there
must be a feeling of trust
and support towards the team to complete
the project's objectives
the next principle emphasizes on
face-to-face conversations with the
development team
the face-to-face conversation helps in
both solving problems
and easy knowledge sharing then the nine
principle
emphasizes on finding solutions and
maximizing the amount of work done
with simplicity this ensures timely
completion of tasks by all the team
members
the last principle states that scrum
tools like monday.com
or zoho sprints must be used to simplify
the complicated
codes which further helps in saving time
we shall now see the steps
in agile project management the goal of
agile methodology
is to produce shorter development life
cycles and more frequent product
releases
than traditional waterfall project
management so we will now check
six steps in agile project methodology
the first step in the process is project
planning
project planning includes feasibility
study development of scope
breaking the project into executable
tasks or sprints
and then estimating the amount of time
needed to complete those prints
the second step is the step of roadmap
creation a roadmap is a plan of action
that shows how a project shall evolve
over time a list of all the features
that the final product should have is
created
and the steps to achieve those features
are taken the next important step is
release planning
since we are doing the project keeping
in mind the agile project methodology
the project will complete in sprints
that means there will be the release of
features
at the end of each cycle and unlike the
traditional waterfall model the
development cycles will be smaller
the fourth step in agile project
management is sprint planning
the sprints are made keeping in mind
what all is to be accomplished
in that particular step at the beginning
of each sprint the goal of that sprint
is decided
and steps to achieve that goal are taken
the next step in the process
emphasizes on daily meetings there are
short meetings every day
to discuss if the team was able to
finish the task for each sprint
and check if there are any amendments
that are required
each team member talks about what they
achieved in the last print and what are
they going to work on
in the next print the last step is the
step of sprint review and retrospective
there are two meetings after each sprint
first meeting is for the sprint review
this meeting is with the stakeholders to
show them the finished product
this helps both sides to build a
relationship and discuss if there are
any
issues in the end product the second
meeting is for having a sprint
retrospective
this meeting involves the stakeholders
to discuss what went well
and what went wrong during the sprint
sprint retrospective
takes place after the sprint review and
before the next print planning
now when we know the steps needed for
agile project methodology
we must understand some agile project
management frameworks
there are several frameworks available
today here
we will be discussing some of the most
popular frameworks
the first framework we will discuss is
the kanban framework
kanban framework is a well-known
framework for implementing
agile software development in the case
of kanban framework
work items are represented on the kanban
board which helps all the team members
to see the state of every piece of work
at any time
kanban board not only helps in
visualizing the work but also optimizing
the workflow among the team
the next framework we will discuss today
is the scrum framework
scrum framework is a popular framework
for managing complex knowledge work
like in the field of research and
advanced technologies
scrum is a simple framework that helps
team work together
and learn through their experiences
gained while working on a problem
the third framework we will see today is
the hybrid framework the hybrid
framework is a combination of
agile methodology and non-agile
methodology
in the case of a hybrid framework
planning is done using the traditional
way of project management
while the execution and delivery is done
using the agile methodology
since the hybrid is a combination of the
two it handles the requirement changes
and delivers the product in different
stages the fourth and the last framework
we will see
is the lean framework the lean framework
works on the principle of providing
maximum customer value
and creating zero waste it focuses on
optimizing the flow of products
all through the value stream this helps
in eliminating waste
all through the process and create
processes that requires
less human efforts this also simplifies
the process
of information management and makes it
more accurate
finally let's have a look at some
companies that have opted for agile
project management
today around 22 percent of the
organizations worldwide
have all their teams working on the
principle of agile project methodology
let's have a look at some of the most
prominent companies in the world
that use agile project management in the
list we have
ibm cisco atnt microsoft
philips and samsung so as part of this
tutorial
we are going to look at what are user
stories
advantages of user stories investing
in user stories how to write user
stories 3 c's of user stories
life cycle of user stories then user
story map and its
advantages now let us look at a typical
scenario of an organization
where the need of user stories would
come in so looking at this scenario so
an organization would have a
scenario where the existing products are
sold very well in the market
and they may think about introducing new
product
or they may think about introducing a
new feature or functionality to the
existing product
so the scenario what we are considering
is it says
our previous product sold really well in
the market
now let's think about new products so
we'll need to make sure
we can understand the requirements and
fulfill the requirements
now how do you do this so how are you
going to understand the consumer
requirements
user requirements and how is that going
to help the user to
accomplish the requirement and fulfill
the need whatever is required to be
fulfilled
so user story helps one who understand
user stories
would look at the perspective of the
users and these user stories
provides those insight towards what user
would exist
so as we go through we will understand
in the perspective of the users
the requirements and how user stories
helps in terms of
fulfilling those requirements this
requires certain amount of visualization
let us see what it is so what are user
stories
user stories are an agile software
development
project management tool that provides
users with simple
natural language explanations of one or
more features
written from the end users perspectives
so for a given product we may have many
end users
so we may develop an application within
an organization
and use that application for an
organization that is one scenario
second scenario is we create a product
we sell it
and employees of our customer
organization will become
users of those products these are the
two scenarios
so having these scenarios what kind of
product it is what is the objective of
this product which is going to fulfill
so let me assume an hr application which
is used for
submission of claims from the employees
so what is that requirement so this
application
should accept the claims submission from
the employees of the organization
and then that needs to be processed and
the claims needs to be
cleared now what will happen now the
user
community if you visualize there is an
user as an employee of an organization
who submit claims
so there is an user in the finance
perspective who is going to deposit the
money
similarly there is an user who is going
to approve
so many such user interfaces we will see
the existence of the roles of users we
will see
who would be using these particular
applications
so in their perspective there should be
an interface provided
there should be some privileges provided
through which they would do their
transactions and activities when we
write the user stories we don't write
them in detail
so a user story doesn't go in detail
it just mentions how a certain type of
work will bring value to end user
so what is this role specific end user
would be
doing at that particular role in this
particular product what is the
transactions involved so the end user in
this case could mean
external end user or even internal
customer or colleagues within the
organization
so looking at these points if i look at
the same application
hr claim processing application who are
these internal users the employees of
organization so who are these
external maybe the people who sold this
particular application to
our organization so they have installed
it they manage it there is an
administration role for this particular
product that is a role similarly another
set of
internal users maybe someone who is like
from finance from hr
so in each of these roles perspective
this particular product should provide
the interface
and then there should be a transaction
in their perspective which is very
important
so user story should explain this in
very brief so that it helps in terms of
visualizing
what kind of interface has to be
provided and why would
this particular role use it that is very
important
so user stories also form the building
block of agile frameworks like epics and
initiatives
so what is this epics what is this
initiative let us look at it
now epics refers to the group of user
stories
where the large amount of work broken
down into user stories so many user
stories together
forms epics which will provide certain
insight towards how
these user stories are connected with
each other
so similarly initiative refers to
combination of multiple epics forming
that
initiatives so which is very essential
to group so managing perspective it will
become easy
and also looking at the objective what
is that particular group of user stories
group of epics are going to accomplish
so
user stories can also help ensuring that
team work to goals of the organization
through epics and initiatives it should
be looking at that objective exactly
what is the directions we are getting
into and how these combination of user
stories
so as an employee i am submitting my
claims so what is that required in that
user's perspective
there should be a story so i as a
finance person i'm going to clear these
claims
i'm going to pay the money deposit the
money so that is
that particular role needs certain
interfaces
and that visualization requires how this
interactions happens
so user story should help in terms of
understanding those
so the requirements for making user
story a reality are added later
after discussing with the team so i we
made an user story we created an user
story
it doesn't end there so there needs to
be discussion which happens further
to decide yes it is a valid user story
so this will also helps in terms of
prioritization which needs to be taken
up first
so user stories are recorded on post it
notes or an index card or a project
management software
and this would help in terms of
prioritization or for tracking as well
so what is the advantages of user
stories so advantages of user story
involves
it helps in delivering high quality
content because
what is required to be accomplished in
the user perspective that will be very
clear
eases collaboration with team members
because finalization on the user stories
and understanding of the user
requirements would happen after
discussing with the team members each
one would give their own
viewpoints and prioritization of
particular user story
or keeping a specific user story or not
considering that user story
would be based on the feedback which
team provides this cannot happen in
terms of
having team members together and
speaking about it helps understanding
users better
so user roles are discussed users
requirement is discussed
and what is that go they are going to
accomplish through this user
interface that is also discussed so user
role is understood user requirement is
clearly understood by writing an user
story this will also help in
improving transparency because since the
collaboration is happening
since the user story is not just taken
just like that the discussion happens
and that will have an interaction and
collaboration
so definitely improves transparency so
now it reduces
risks so when i say risk it's obviously
uncertainty
so it reduces risk because the clarity
one would have
about the requirement of users so
accordingly
the features functionality of the
product are defined so that they can
fulfill those user requirements
then supports iterative developments as
i mentioned earlier
the collaboration the transparency
everyone working together
and in the agile perspective users
stories epics and initiatives gets into
the specific iterations
only after this discussion with the team
members and after prioritizing it
so the user story will be there in the
product backlogs which will be
prioritized based on that particular
scenario of requirement in agile
scenario so
as when we say giant it's quite obvious
we need to be flexible to the changing
scenarios so since we're working
together
and when we go for an iterative mode of
approach
it's quite obvious we're going for it to
get adopting to the
changing scenario so that we can select
that particular features functionality
by pulling that particular epic or user
story as a priority
in the given list so that prioritization
making will also become
easier focuses on local communications
means
lot of interactions happens while
discussing on user stories
so since people are doing it locally so
there is some personal touch also
established
could collaboration can get established
so user story also provides that
visibility because of that
people working together in a
collaborative manner invest
in user stories so what is invest so
investing in user stories so what does
that mean so it is a concept that helps
creating
meaningful user stories so it stands for
independent negotiable valuable
esteemable sized appropriately
testable so when i say independent
so whenever we write the user story that
should be
self-contained if at all possible
to avoid dependencies on other user
stories so it should be independent of
one another
so that each of them can be developed
and delivered separately
so negotiable so when we say negotiable
user stories can always be changed or
re-written
so at any given point in time so we
should be able to do that modifications
required
so that should support the flexibility
associated with the
agile methodologies so since
requirements often
evolve changes and these changes comes
for various different reasons
so how do we change these user stories
or modify this so that it can fit into
the requirement so that adaption can
happen to the
changing requirements so story should be
discussable
and should be open for negotiation for
any change scenarios
so next valuable when i say valuable
it's quite obvious we're speaking about
value what is being created for the
users or consumers
so a user story would represent the goal
or an objective an end user
who is going to look for means value is
always in the consumer's perspective
so now i created certain features
functionality is fine but did that
really create the value to the consumers
so the value realization plays an
important role so stories must ensure
there is a value being added to the
consumers
and customers or users always otherwise
user story doesn't make
any sense so esteemable so when we say
estimable
one should always be able to estimate
the size of the user story so sometimes
developers may not have the experience
required to size the particular
situations
or needed for an user story reasons may
be anything
it may be not having specific insight
towards it
or don't know how to estimate there may
be someone specific who needs to
understand that scenarios and then
come and discuss reasons maybe anything
so stories if you cannot estimate
then it will become difficult in terms
of handling it better so it should give
some visualization
so it should be estimable and can be
divided into tasks
so now small means sized appropriately
so user story should not be very big or
should not be too small
and then how do we decide on this size
so now when we say any user story that
can be completed by a developer in
single iterations
then can we call it as too big quite
obviously that is again
indicative so user story should be
subdivided into two or more small
stories
into multiple pieces multiple stories
small small story so that it can be
handled better so story should not be
too big
and should be completed within 40 hours
or three to four days this numbers are
indicative
so not necessarily you should be fixing
with this number so just an indicative
to
show you that what would be the focus
when i say user story in
what is that effort it would take to
accomplish that
now testable so when we say
user story is testable one has to ensure
that development is complete and has
been done correctly
so means one once you create a user
story
so that needs to be articulated in such
a way so that it becomes measurable when
i say testable
obviously there should be metrics a
target metrics which can be created
which will help me to state yes this
particular requirement is accomplished
so they should have an acceptance
criteria that can be tested to check
if they fulfill the customer's need so
then how to write user story this is
very
important point to look at so how to
write the user story
so writing user stories comes up with a
specific template with a
simple language so what is it so now as
a role i want to so that
so you keep filling it so typically
role means what the specific user role
who would be using that particular
product and their requirements which are
being fulfilled
so that is the role the name of the role
we are going to put it here
so the role refers to an individual that
would be
interfacing or interacting with the
system
now one two when we say one two
the want or action which represents the
behavior of the systems
so what is that it's supposed to do this
action would be unique to each
user stories now so that this refers to
the benefits or results
that non-functional and external to the
system as a result what would happen
what is that we are trying to accomplish
out of it so let us look at
an example how does it look like as a
ceo
i want to track my subordinates progress
to ensure
organizations goals are met similarly if
we take the reference to those
examples what we discussed earlier like
we took the example of
a chart portal so claim processing
requirement now
this can be same user story as an
employee of an organization what can i
write
so as an employee of this organization
i want to submit my claims online
so that claim processing will become
smoother easier
faster without any errors so that can
also be user story so it
gives certain visualization what kind of
users are there and what is that
they need so the moment you write the
user stories
you should visualize that rule it is
very important so there is three seas of
user stories
which we call it as card
then conversation and then confirmation
so when we say card card provides a
written description of the user story
so what do i mean by written description
of the user story
so same thing the user story what we
just saw as an example
so that can be written on a card so this
will help in
planning and estimating so what and that
will also gives that
visualization of users and their
requirement
so that that can be articulated further
and also estimated
so that it can looked in the perspective
of
invest what is invest what we discussed
so it is
independent it is negotiable it is
valuable it is estimable it is
sized appropriately means it should not
be too big too small
the examples what we saw was appropriate
and testable
so now when we see this particular user
story
is it fulfilling all those points what
we discussed
in invest that is very important now
this card whatever the description is
provided
should elaborate on that very clearly so
then further what happens
conversation after the user story is
written in a card and given
and it is shared with the every
individuals who is participating in that
conversation
so then there will be discussion so
conversation represents discussion
between
users team product owners
so this helps in terms of whatever the
user story is written
is it making sense is it in line with
the user's expectation
and at the same time whatever the
understanding we have maybe as
a product owner or the team member a
developer
is my understanding correct then user
perspective so whatever the user story
is written
is that user story is speaking about the
requirement which needs to be fulfilled
as they require so this helps to build a
shared understanding between
all those individuals so that there is
no confusion further
so once people converse together once
the stakeholders converse together
then you will confirm confirmation so
this represents the condition
that need to be satisfied to ensure that
the
story meets all requirements so you are
confirming
so all the stakeholders are agreeing to
that
so firstly to summarize this three c's
refers to
card conversation confirmation card
provides the user stories
which actually represents as we took an
example so which will capture that
so that it also fulfills the thought of
invest
then conversation is required to
understand what is this user story
speaking about
is that a real requirement so
confirmation further in terms of
confirmation from users as well as all
the stakeholders
before you go and develop or execute
that
so what is life cycle of user story so
when we say life cycle
so we may require to understand a life
cycle starts when you
conceptualize when you visualize when
you say this is what we may require to
accomplish though they should be
consuming someone should consume that
idea
so it may be a related to a problem it
may be related to a specific product uh
for an opportunity what is seen
so whatsoever the reason it is there is
a scenario where something is conceived
trigger may be a problem trigger may be
some issues what is being faced
trigger may be an opportunity what is
same so
then the initiative the trigger which
actually pushed towards
creation of the requirements and user
stories so the life cycle of user story
starts from there
so how does it go so it involves
right from the point pending to to do
then discussion then developing
conforming and then
finished so when i say pending i'm
basically saying
user stories in their most basic forms
where they are created after
communicating with the user
and the project team these acts as a
reminder for further discussion
so first level of understanding on user
stories in the basic form
so which will help in terms of further
discussion
and taking a call on that so will there
be a possibility
that this user stories will be modified
as we progress answer is yes
and no both so it may be modified but
discussion is
further which goes on from this basic
understanding of that particular user
story
so further discussion is to elaborate on
that make sense out of it
and confirm so then after discussion
with the stakeholders
users stories that need to be addressed
are
decided and put into sprints so in
between
the point where we set pending to to do
so in between this
there is a lot of discussion so where
decision is happening here so decided
and put into sprints means there is a
prioritization also which is happening
so now discussion at this stage user
confirms users confirms the requirement
and acceptance criterias
so acceptance criteria helps in terms of
once you test that particular user story
after executing you will check based on
these acceptance criteria so that you
can conclude the requirement is
fulfilled
the end users are shown a preview of
upcoming features
so that they understand yes this is what
we were expecting they can provide their
feedback necessary feedbacks or insights
whatever is required to be
provided so then once the discussion is
complete
the team would be able to design and
implement
features to fulfill user requirements so
once user
concludes yes this is what we were
expecting and there is a sign off
during the discussion then features are
developed and implemented
so that it can go to that product which
can be used
so then after developing conforming
so the end user confirms there is a
story features are confirmed to testing
environments
alpha versions and acceptance criterias
are looked at
before saying yes it is confirmed user
is accepting
so that will happen as part of
confirming means that features or
functionality what was written in user
story
so that specific users are using it and
concluding or acknowledging yes
this is fulfilling our requirement and
this is according to the acceptance
criteria
what we discussed and agreed so that is
very important so we write a user story
fine
but users are not agreeing to it that is
not a good scenario to be with
user should accept and confirm then
finished
so the user store is completed at this
stage for new requirements or new
features a new user story must be
created
any new features or new functionality i
am required to add to this particular
product
then i would write another user story
and the same life cycle starts continues
and this is not an ending thing so as i
keep modifying the features
as i add new features add a as i look at
improving the performances so i keep
writing the user stories
now one question keeps coming to me so
we write a user story
while fulfilling the requirements fine
as a specific user i want this
easy to narrate that so how are we going
to look at a scenario
where there is an improvement of
something so whenever we are going to
discuss about improvement of something
it is quite obvious we need to look at
it what is that improvement user is
looking at
now when i am submitting a particular
request
or accessing something it is taking some
time
means there is some delay now user
experience can be enhanced
by reducing that particular time that is
improvement
as a user the user story basic user
story doesn't change
but in the performance perspective you
may require to visualize that so problem
statement has to come in accordingly
user story has to be
articulated then once the user store is
written it is required to
put there is user story mapping so user
story mapping
represents and arranges user stories
that help with understanding the systems
functionalities
the systems backlog planning releases
and providing value to the customers so
typically
this involves arranging or organizing
user stories
based on the priority along the
horizontal axis
so it will horizontally when you move so
i will say which one is the priority
which user stories are priority
first thing which i need to focus on so
vertical arrangements represents
how in the given specific user story how
the
activities perspective task perspective
sub task perspective
further down how it gets elaborated to
improving the levels
how it goes forward so now let us look
at
an user story mapping with an example of
let me see net banking
services provided by a bank for account
holders when i say net banking service
it is quite obvious it is also has to be
provided through having a product
which banking application would use so
but here we need to visualize
the user's journey while accessing the
net banking portal
viewing the account details paying bills
like utility bills doing a lot of
transactions within that
particular portal at banking access the
moment they do
like generating statements or
transferring money to one of the benefit
beneficiaries etc so all these
transactions so what is being done
so in this user story map let us see how
does it look like so
few activities are considered here like
uh
logging into the account means net
banking portal will come in
then one would input their credentials
and then they log in
now that journey of the users in a
specific
activity what they do is visualized now
login to account in the sense
obviously one has to go to that portal
so go to login page
then enter credentials login id and
password
so once that login id and password is
entered obviously there is a process
engine which runs behind
to provide the necessary access now if
that credentials are not working or
if i don't remember it reset password is
an option immediately
now as i go through further from this
sub task
in all the particular columns which have
given you
as you go through this as i deep dive
into it further it goes on
so until the person gets an access to
the account and then start doing the
transactions
it goes up to that level so i can keep
writing the subtask further so manage
account
so you would go to account page once you
access it then you'll select the
specific account because you may have
many different account
types which is there with the bank you
may be having one or many so in the
scenario you have more than one
obviously you will select that account
and account details will be displayed to
you so this user will not do but user
will get that
so we are visualizing that and further
after account details are
displayed what user would do then
further you would
keep visualizing that so some of the
transaction like
generating statement transferring money
so even for that the steps are written
so going to statement page then
selecting the account for which you need
a statement
then selecting the period from when to
when the statement one is requiring
and then further clicking on it and
downloading that particular statement
or choosing an options mentioning that
i need this an email or i need an hard
copy of this
so similarly transferring money so you
will go to that specific wage where
you need to transfer the money so you
may have the beneficiary there
in the list already added if you have
added earlier
or newly you're adding a beneficiary so
there are various types of transfers
like so international transfer you will
have local domestic transfer will have
within a bank accounts being within the
same
bank bank a two consumers so from me
if i'm a consumer transferring money to
another consumer of the same bank
and vice versa that is one of the
options second is a
bank consumer having and transferring
your money to
some other bank account of someone else
that is another scenario or
transferring money for my own account in
another bank so various different
scenarios you come across
so then limitation or depending on what
kind of
beneficiaries are these what is the
limitations and how are you going to
authenticate them
so the moment i visualize a specific
transaction and activities of user
stories what are the things an user can
do then i can keep writing
mapping this to each of those flow
and see how the flow happens so this
flow
helps me to bring in all those features
and functionality
and also prioritizing them so can i say
the beneficiary option would be the
basic thing which
consumer would give i think initially if
i go back when actually that banking
features were provided by the bank
the basic thing was just viewing the
account that was the given statement
download was given
otherwise uh there was no opportunity to
transfer money there was no opportunity
to
do something beyond that so now as we
see today the lot of flexibility has
brought in with
lot of new features functionalities in
the net banking or mobile banking
options
so they evolve so as they evolve it is
quite obvious
we may require to keep adding those
features functionality
by writing the user stories this is how
the enhancement happens
so overall if you look at user story
mapping helps in terms of
understanding not just the user story of
one transaction
associated transaction in the user story
what happens throughout the journey that
will help
so this will also support to understand
and visualize what needs to be created
to ultimately give that
access to the user so the end-to-end
flow should be visualized
and also needs to be prioritization and
has to be looked at as well now what are
the advantages of user story mapping
so the advantages wise helps with
prioritizing work
as i explained in an example similarly
the focus is on user value the moment i
click on web page
www.abcbank.com
now the bank page will come i will have
an interface of login i will go and
click on login
now from the point i open a browser and
input that url and then click on login
and login page comes in how long it
takes
so there are many things which is
involved the browser things are involved
the system
from which the person is accessing is
involved so removing that part so
thinking that both of them working well
and what should be the response
from the server where this particular
website is hosted
that experience needs to be looked at so
that's how you look at user value in the
transaction
now once i put a credentials now how
quickly the authentication happens
what are the checks the bank portal does
to ensure that the person who is logging
in
is a genuine user is it just a password
is there any captcha codes
is there any otp sent or is there any
secret code the person has to put in
so likewise many things are involved
while giving that
experience to the user so and today's
user if you just put in various
different checks points they understand
because they're very educated
so white all those things like captcha
or otp
scenario scheming so these are came in
because more and more inform the people
has become
then their ability to hack also improve
so more and more levels added to
ensure that only that genuine user will
enter the user account
similarly when you visualize any product
and user journey
in the user's interest what are the
things which is going to create
value that needs to be understood so
only that experience will help
for the user to realize the benefit then
roadblocks are highlighted
so as we visualize this journey so this
will tell me so what would stop me to
move forward
is there any concerns is there any
constraints
like for example if you want to activate
a beneficiary but
for some limited period you can only
send the limited amount of money
why is that done by chance if the
beneficiary is added by that individual
who is not a genuine user so we are
actually holding it
right so by the time that freezing time
whatever is given so by the time the
message goes to the actual consumer
telling that there is a user activated
like this and if at all if
it is not a genuine user obviously the
person can call to the bank saying that
this is not
the beneficiary which i have added
there's something which is
not correct so they are giving that
space so how did
they visualize this has to be done so as
we looked at the journey of adding a
beneficiary it's quite obvious
when beneficial is added if by chance
someone who is not authorized adds it
so who is going to this benefit
obviously user will be disbenefited
so that blocks that constraints are
visualized
similarly in making or creating that
features functionality
what should be the basic features or in
the product should be ready
only then i can add this feature even
that will be visible
right so roadblocks will be highlighted
and that those will be made visible
so that easy for you to move forward
prioritizing and ensuring that
it goes in the flow required to
accomplish that value
so then ensuring team unity because
everyone will have a visualization
user stories and mapping reads a lot of
discussion
brings the people to have a common
understanding so obviously
that unity the collaboration would come
in focus on constant improvement
so improvement is the key whatever you
do you
you just adopted a waterfall methodology
you have just adopted an agile
you write user stories you raise their
peaks you write bring in that
various different methods to do
something whatever you do whether it is
product or a service or a process or a
specific transactions task
reports whatever we make so all that
should
help in terms of identifying the
opportunities for improvement
and making that improvements that is
very important
today as all of us know agile has become
a
well-known development methodology and
the approach of choice for
many development teams especially those
trying to create an environment of
continuous delivery when we think of
agile
we often think of high levels of
collaboration and flexibility
as well as iterative environment in
which
requirements evolve alongside the
changing needs
so as a result we also tend to
conceptualize agile as an approach
that helps development teams across
various industries
deliver new features faster but how do
we get there
what does history of agile entire
and how can knowing the history of agile
helpers better understand the
methodology
and its positive impact on today's
development world
let us look at it so now
historically if you see the waterfall
approach was
fine it was delivering the required
value but it required teams to
stick to the requirements and scope of
work
set out at the very beginning of the
project
and not make any changes or additions
along the way as the project progresses
and following that fixed plan could
prove trouble sometimes
comparing to the scenarios which we had
earlier versus today
the trouble is more challenges more
so reason being waterfall methodology
prioritized bringing a complete product
to market
meaning it could take years before teams
finish the project in hand
the scenarios of change delay in
responding to problem resolution
meeting changing market requirements
were challenging
which led to introduction of agile
methodologies
so the various development methods like
scrum
rapid application development extreme
programming dsdm
feature driven development and pragmatic
program
were introduced so it all started
early i think in 2001 it was introduced
however it all started in the spring of
2000
when a group of 17 software developers
in oregon to discuss
how they could speed up development in
order to bring new software to market
faster
so they recognized two key opportunities
that achieving this goal would make
possible
so reducing the time to the benefits for
those users
in order to resolve the product market
fit and development problems
secondly getting feedback from users
quickly to confirm
the usefulness of new software and
continue to improve on it accordingly
so further these group of 17 developers
met again
at a ski resort in snowbird utah
us so they created popularly known as
agile manifesto
so which laid out four key values
so which says individuals and
interactions or processes and tools
working software over comprehensive
documentation
customer collaboration or contract
negotiation
responding to change or following the
plan are
valued more now
further between the time when it was
introduced till today
agile has become popular and adoption of
that has increased
reason being the flexibility the agile
brought into the system
so several organizations across the
world started using it
but what happened further so agile gave
the result but there was a challenge so
there were some issues that agile face
to handle
widespread use age that is mainly
whenever there is a scalability
requirements
so what is that scalability challenges
it is quite obvious
how can an implementation of agile for
large and more complex project
and how hard the process to scale agent
so this was not clear
the very reason the challenge which come
across
which the practitioners actually faced
was
one is lack of experience with agile
methodologies
little understanding of frameworks
methods and how to implement
them next large-scale coordination
so when i say specific project a small
project it was easy implementation of
agile and then
going forward all these frameworks what
i mentioned earlier it was easy but the
moment you want to do scaling to the
bigger organization the complex
environment
the coordination collaboration
dependency management between
usually distributed teams geographically
distributed teams was challenging
and thirdly having a clear understanding
of
what needs to be completed in the
sprints and what the bigger picture is
so fourth aligning the entire
organization
and managing commitment so definitely
organization
required alignment the products or
services which are being produced by the
project needs an alignment
so the need of alignment was basically
to ensure
the organization gets the value out of
whatever they have invested
so fifth unrealistic expectation with
respect to speed of delivery
so unable to respond to this particular
scenario
so that organization can able to respond
quickly so it was not happening so time
to
benefits i i was mentioning about so
generally
earlier we used to speak about time to
market but today it has been replaced by
time to benefits how
quickly the value of that particular
product or services
introduced to the market is realized by
the users that is very important
so the framework of scaling agile there
are various different frameworks
so some of the most effective ways to
scale agile
would be large scale scrum which is
called a celes
scaled agile framework disciplined agile
scrum at scale nexus scrum the spotify
model so when i say less the large-scale
scrum
it is a way of scaling agile and scaling
scrum
to large and big product development
groups
it has been used since 2005 in different
software and hardware products in
industries such as banking
and telecom so when it comes to scaled
agile framework
so it is a set of organizations and
workflow patterns
intended to guide enterprise in scaling
lean and agile practices
so it is made freely available by scaled
agile link
which retains the copyrights and
registered trademarks
so the disciplined agile delivery which
is also called as dad
is a software development portion of the
disciplined agile toolkit
so dad enables teams to make simplified
process decisions
around incremental and iterative
solution delivery
so that builds on many practices by
advocates of agile software development
including scrum
agile modeling liens of development and
others
so scrum at scale so scrum
originally if you look at outline in the
scrum guide
is a framework for developing delivering
and sustaining complex products by a
single theme
so since its inceptions its usage was
extended to the
creation of products processes services
and systems
that require the efforts of multiple
teams whereas
scrum at scale was created to
efficiently coordinate this new
ecosystem of teams
it achieves this goal through setting up
a minimum viable bureaucracy
via scale free architecture now coming
to next one the nexus
scrum so this consists of multiple cross
functional scrum team working together
to deliver a potentially releasable
integrated increment at least by the end
of each print
based on dependencies the teams may
self-organize
and select the most appropriate members
to do specific work
so lastly the spotify model which is
basically people-driven
autonomous framework for scaling agile
while emphasizing the importance of
culture and network
this methodology uses squads tribes
chapters guilds the foundation which is
called which acts like
scrum team so for that let us look at
the our focus area of this particular
video
which is basically what is scaled agile
framework
so scaled agile framework as i mentioned
earlier
consists of collection of principles
best practices
and processes that would enable large
organizations to
adopt agile methodologies so it would
help them deliver products
and services of the highest quality
faster
so safe is best suited for complex
projects
that involves several large teams at the
projects
program and portfolio levels the current
version of
safe is version 5 which has seven core
competencies based on which it can help
organizations
the large organization is specific so
safe has certain core values
which are basically alignment
built-in quality transparency
and program execution so when i say
alignment
so i was mentioning about aligning with
business
requirement business strategies so it is
needed to keep pace with
fast changing disruptive competitive
forces and geographically distributed
teams
while empowered agile teams are good
even great
but the responsibility for strategy and
alignment
cannot rest with the combined opinions
of the teams no matter how good they are
instead
alignment must rely on enterprises
business objective
so it also need to require to keep up
with the change
the competitions and then the dynamics
across
in the environment where organization is
doing their business
so next is built-in quality so built-in
quality is basically to ensure
that every element and every increment
of the solutions
reflect quality standards throughout the
development lifecycle
so quality is not added later building
quality
is prerequisite of lean and
flow without it the organization will
likely operate with
large batches of unverified unvalidated
work which leads to
the product or services which is not
okay and also that would lead towards
excessive rework which is not good
and slower velocities which is not allow
the organization to respond quickly to
the dynamics of the
market so third one is transparency
so transparency which basically need to
enable
teams to rely on each other there should
be trust which needs to be built
so based on which high performance can
happen so wherever the
trust exists so when the business and
development can confidently rely on
each other to act with integrity
particularly
in times of responding quickly or to
work on a solution for resolving
something which is actually
not allowing things to move forward so
without trust
no one can build high performance teams
and programs
so the confidence needed to make
reasonable commitments is
very very essential so fourth
is program execution so
safe focuses on working systems and
business outcomes
which mainly for example for teams to
execute and continuously deliver value
safe places and intense focus on working
systems
and business outcomes so this is because
while many enterprises
start the transformation with individual
agile teams
they often become frustrated as even
those
teams struggle to deliver more
substantial amount of solution value
reliability and efficiently
so delivering solutions with better
value
reliability and efficiency effectiveness
is very very essential and here we're
speaking about ensuring
the scalability to the bigger
organization
so program management plays a very
important role so that requires lot of
communication collaboration so without
a better execution of that without
handling it better things cannot
go the way it is required so various
competencies
safe recommends so safe competencies
involves team and technical agility
agile product delivery enterprises
solution delivery
lean portfolio management organizational
agility
continuous learning culture and then
lean agile leadership
so when i say team and technical agility
so agile teams are high performing and
cross-functional
business solutions are built by business
and technical teams
delighting customers with high quality
output so this requires
an able team which understand agile
frameworks which
follows it which complies with it and
also technically
sound so agile product delivery
which actually refers to the scenario
where the customer is at the center of
organization's product strategy
so development is based on cadence and
releases on demand
exploring integrity deploying and
innovating continuously
then enterprise solution delivery so
building
big system with the help of lean
coordinating and aligning the entire
supply chain
evolving the live system continuously
requires to ensure the visibility of
entire enterprises and providing
solution accordingly lean portfolio
management
which basically focuses on aligning the
strategy
funding and execution optimizing
operations across the portfolio
decentralized decision making powered by
lightweight governance
then organizational agility a lean agile
mindset is created across the enterprise
it is very essential
for example i am working in a project i
have an attrition
if hr does not understand my project
dynamics
and if they are not agile me as a
project organization becoming agile will
not help
similarly the one the procurement
similarly
the processes so very essential for all
the
organization units to become agile so
that
business operations are able to
complement contribute that speed or the
change what is required
so opportunities and threats are
addressed quickly so risks are
identified
and addressed quickly so they are worked
on it so risk management can become
easier with the involvement of right
stakeholders continuous learning culture
so in this scenario everyone learns and
grows together
exploration creativity are a very
important part of organization where
there should be
innovation creation execution
maybe i think i come across certain
terms like intelligent risk taking
so learning through failures
failure should lead towards enquiry not
towards blaming
so these are all the things which are
more and more discussed when we
want to make an organization a learning
organization
the continuous improvement of solutions
services
and processes is everyone's
responsibility
then lean agile leadership so by
modeling desired behaviors
inspiring others aligning words actions
and mindset to lean agile principles and
values
lead change and guide others so this
requires lot of accountability
and ensuring the correct information
well informed individuals to
take forward things now how does safe
work
so safe considering those competencies
what we looked at
the seven competencies so let us see
what happens in each of the competences
how does safe work using these
competencies so firstly let us look at
team and technical agility
which basically involves an agile team
of
5-11 members which helps defining
build test and deploy products
so this is done by dividing the task
into small
easier to manage time boxed iterations
right then chrome team led by the scrum
master
and supported by product owner plan and
then deliver the product in increments
so further after delivery they have a
retrospective to determine
how the iterations went and how it can
be improved
this is incorporated into next
iterations planning phase
so the method used here could be scrum
or kanban
so both are popular the combination of
this can be used
so scrum basically helps in ensuring
that
things moves in iterations and
everything is visible and delivered
whereas kanban supports in terms of
making it more visible
and able to manage it better
so agile product delivery so a large
organization
usually consists of several agile teams
each led by their respective scrum
masters
so these teams together represent agile
release trains also called as art
so they usually involve 50 to 125 people
so art are cross-functional and involve
everyone who understand customer needs
and can help with building and
delivering the solution
required so art uses an agile delivery
practices
like the one used by the teams to
deliver value to the customers
so it uses time box iterations called
program increments or pis
which usually involves four to five
iterations
all the teams they get together to plan
their
work during pi planning events so they
should work together they should have
full visibility while doing it
so three major components which are
required
when we do agile product delivery is
release drain engineer
then project management and then system
architect
so release train engineer represents the
coach of the art
facilitated the pa planning process
the project management provides the
vision for the project
and backlog of the tasks system
architect
provides architectural guidance for the
process
and then the teams then make plans
regarding what they would be able to
deliver so the program board is
also drawn up to determine dependencies
between the teams
which also goes through program
iterations the pis as i mentioned
earlier
then after every iterations the art
shows
the integrated output to all teams
through a system demo
so after the pi is complete all team get
together to retrospect
event called the inspect and adapt
events
so further a continuous delivery
pipeline is set up
based on the art devops practices are
also used to ensure values available on
demand
i think the term devops is becoming more
and more popular today
which actually providing that visibility
need for collaboration need for cultural
transformation
so which helps in terms of bringing that
agility across the organization
as well as learning organization so one
of the
principles of devops itself says
continuous learning
there should be continuous
experimentation and learning
risk taking intelligence risk taking and
also we come across speaking the
concepts like semian army concept like
introducing
failures into existing systems and learn
what can fail and what is the solution
for it and that can help in terms of
becoming more resilient and reliable
system
so devops has become popular and
adoption of that discussion on that is
uh become more common across the
organizations
so next enterprise solution delivery so
enterprise solution delivery let us look
at a scenarios where a single art may
not be able to deliver an appropriate
solution
a solution train which coordinates
multiple arts and suppliers
would be able to provide solutions in
large and complex scenarios
so meaning consideration of enterprise
has a whole
seeing end-to-end organization entire
visibility
so basically what is that we are trying
to achieve so alignment we discussed
about which requires the objective of
organization because organization is
investing
so whatever we do at various different
levels should complement to each other
rather than
contradicting so that complementing
thought or complementing visibility can
happen
only when someone has a bigger
visibility enterprise
world while outlook
then the three major components that are
required in enterprise solution delivery
would be solution management solutions
architect
and solution train engineer the solution
management
holds content authority or what needs to
be built
solution architect handles the
architecture
across the arts solution train engineer
enables coaching and facilitating of
solutions train events
so next is lean portfolio management
so lean portfolio management provides
ways of creating and combining strategic
themes and portfolio vision
this enables solution development to be
aligned with enterprise strategy
so the moment i say lean firstly we
should keep in mind that
it's about creating value to the
stakeholders that is first thing
second thing is elimination of waste now
when i link this to strategy
when i link to towards the
organization's directions what it says
and while going in the directions i
should ensure
no defects are actually moved
downstreams or
are eliminated when it goes to
downstream
so customer should see the value which
is very important and identification of
all the contributions of waste
has to be done and eliminated so this
ensures there is a value in
organizations value stream
which also ensures that these value
streams
remain funded so funding plays a very
important role
so next is organizational agility
so when i say organizational agility it
should ensure the
organizations various business units in
the organizations
should be with that dynamics of agility
which organization is going through
which organization is moving through
as i mentioned earlier if you have a
project where you have you have adopted
agile methodologies
it's quite obvious for your pace for
your flexibility for your speed
other business units which are working
with you to support you should also
complement to that
they cannot become slower they cannot
have their own pace of
uh doing things like in your project you
have a procurement you have a
recruitment
you have some claims to be cleared from
a char
maybe you're dependent on certain tools
and environments now if these are not
agile if these are not responding in the
same flexibility or same
speed what the agile project team
requires then obviously things will not
flow further
now when i say agile obviously we
introduce products or services quickly
to the environment
now someone needs to manage we have
operations
now can operations manage the products
or services which they are not
aware of now even there the agility is
required
as i keep introducing the new products
or services to the environment
operations should also be well informed
and educated about it so that they can
monitor and manage them effectively and
efficiently
if they fail i think users will not have
a good experience
your product or services may have a
great features functionalities
but however if whenever there is a query
about that product features or
functionality
whenever there is an issue the incident
which user actually calls
the first point of contact for users
would be the operations
the moment operations fails to respond
with the right clarifications or rights
resolution quickly then obviously user
experience
will result in not a good way i think
customer satisfaction or customer
delight
will be at stake so an operation should
become a job
so rest of the business units which are
supporting like funding we spoke about
the funding is not done in agile way
obviously
the things cannot move smoother or
easier so everything across organization
should become agile organizational
agility has to be ensured
so enabling portfolio with strategic
agility
making change in the direction depending
on the scenario
then encouraging the growth of lean
thinking people
and agile teams so people should be
working towards ensuring creating value
always
every task every transaction is what
they do should be enabled through it
so they should also know whatever we are
doing
how this particular task or the work or
the results what i am creating
results in value addition or value
creation to the organization
does it really align to the
organization's requirement is it
fulfilling
maybe customer as a stakeholder or my
own organization the business unit which
is actually investing on this project
so in that context or in that
perspective everyone should be aware of
that alignment
the directions the vision then
focusing on value and helping with
organizing and reorganizing
building an environment for the flow of
value across the organization so
everyone should realize value
so value is what value can be defined in
the perspective of
every individual's background and every
individual's requirement because it's a
perceived one
so there may be real thing what we have
created but perception is different
so the perceived versus what is actually
created
should be as close as possible so zero
deviation is expectation
but difficult but however it should have
a tendency towards it
it should actually be very near to that
perceived reality
but two things involved one is that i
create a features and functionality for
my product or services which fulfills
customer requirements
customer may not know not well educated
not aware of it
and don't know how to realize that value
how to know how these features and
functionalities can be used
so now if you educate that customer the
user how to use it what are the values
it can create and
do some exercise in terms of educating
training coaching
customer can visualize it and just
understand that that is one possibility
second thing is customer is very mature
and our product does not have features
and functionality required
so these are the two scenarios which
required lot of interactions and
engagement
so that increasing in terms of usage of
products and services and realizing
those values
so this has to be encouraged more and
more
so further continuous learning culture
so when we say
learning it's quite obvious organization
should keep maturing
individuals in organization should keep
maturing in terms of capabilities
in terms of ability to do new things
innovate
the knowledge the capability skills
competencies
so that can be possible only through
learning
so learning should be continuous so this
ensures an
atmosphere of innovation and constant
improvement until
organizations becomes a learning
organization
so meaning at every level each
individuals each professionals each
engineers each executives invest their
time in learning
they learn through what they're doing
they go through formal
training they bring in that formal
training learning into the actions here
further they learn so continuous
experimentation
creating an hypothesis working on those
hypotheses
aligning that to the requirement of
organizations
and seeing how is it complementing to
the organization's requirement
so seeing through these are very
essential so the organization which is
having the culture of continuous
learning can sustain and
grow continually there is a question of
looking back
if organization has a scenario of not
learning
they will fade away they may fail to
exist so it is very much required to
understand the market dynamics
continuous learning there
capabilities and skill enhancement
continuous learning here
innovations and making things better
continuous learning
so continuous learning helps
organization to be there in the industry
and continue with the competition so
next is
lean agile leadership so it's quite
obvious
leadership plays very important role
it's about
guiding it's about owning it's about
showing directions
it's about ensuring everyone does the
task everybody is motivated
so the leaders must embody teach and
exhibit
lean and agile principles and values so
firstly they should understand what it
is
they should be aware of it they should
have an exposure to it
they should have full awareness of it as
i was learning about continuous
learning culture in the previous point
so leaders should do that first so only
then i think the followers will
actually have learning adopted to
themselves and things move smoother and
better
and this should happen across the
organization
so by doing this it is quite obvious
organization can become better agile
organization is complemented
to achieve the objectives and goals what
they wanted to accomplish
and there is a safe configurations which
one needs to ensure which involves
essential safe raj solution safe
portfolio safe and full safe
so when i say essential safe it acts as
the foundation for
all safe configurations and is the
easiest
starting point for implementation so
large solution safe it is used for
building large and complex solutions
whereas portfolio safe
provides principles and strategies that
can enable
business agility in an enterprise so
when i say portfolio
it should be understood as portfolio of
an organization as a whole
the service portfolio the product
portfolio the business portfolio
so understanding of that and
complementing to that is very essential
so full safe is a comprehensive
configuration that includes
all competencies and ensures business
agility
so advantages and disadvantages of safe
so advantages involves
enabling decentralized decision making
it eases collaboration across
cross-functional teams
it ensures decisions are made with
strategic
objectives in mind so disadvantages
include
additional layers of oversight which
makes it resemble the waterfall approach
the top down approach can limit
understanding of the software lifecycle
and cause
bad planning so visibility providing
that visibility is very essential
then larger planning cycles and roles
that are fixed in
development cycles in this session we
will be learning about the two most
popular
software development lifecycle models we
will be understanding
the contrast between the agile model and
the waterfall model
of software development so without any
further ado
let's get started now before having a
look at the differences in the two
models
it is important to understand the basics
of software development life cycle
and the need for it
as the name suggests software
development lifecycle
is a process that is used in any
software industry
to design develop and test a software
the goal of the lifecycle is to meet the
quality standards of a software
a software is always made keeping in
mind
the customer expectations time deadlines
and cost estimations
the framework is a collection of steps
in which different tasks
are defined and performed at every step
let's have a look at all the steps
involved in the process of software
development
software development lifecycle has six
different stages
the first stage is planning and
requirement analysis
it is the most important and fundamental
stage
in this step the inputs are taken from
everyone
involved in the process this information
is then used to plan the basic project
approach
and to conduct product feasibility study
this helps the project
to excel in the economical operational
and technical areas
then comes the second step that is the
defining phase
or the requirement defining phase once
the analysis of requirements is done
this step involves defining them and
getting them approved
by the customer this is made possible
through a document called an srs
or software requirement specification
document
this consists of all the product
requirements to be designed
and developed during the project life
cycle
after the defining phase comes the
designing phase
the srs that was made in the last step
is now used as a reference
to construct the project on the basis of
the srs
a design document specification or dds
is documented which helps in deciding
the designing approach of the project
the next step is the building or
development
as the name suggests the actual
development starts in this step
the code for the software is generated
as per the dds documented in the
previous stage
for the code the programming language is
chosen with respect
to the type of software being developed
after the development the step of
testing the product
comes into the picture this stage refers
to the stage where the product defects
are reported
tracked fixed and retested this is done
until the product reaches the quality
standards defined in the srs
the last phase is the deployment phase
after the testing is done
and the product is ready to be deployed
it is formally released in the market
the product may first be released in a
limited segment
and tested in the real business
environment then based on the feedback
the product may be released as it is or
with some upgradations in the market
now when we know the steps of the
software development life cycle
let's have a look at the sdlc models
there are several software development
lifecycle models defined
and designed which are followed during
the software development process
these models may be referred to as
software development process models
every model has its own set of unique
steps
to attain success there are several sdlc
models in the market
here we will be discussing the two most
popular models
the waterfall model and the agile model
so let's begin with
what is waterfall methodology
the waterfall model or the waterfall
methodology
was the first process model to be
introduced
it is a linear sequential life cycle
model
that is easy to understand and operate
in the waterfall model each phase must
be completed before the next phase
has to begin the next phase entirely
depends on the output
or deliverables of the previous phase
the entire process of software
development is divided into a sequence
of several phases
all the phases can be seen as a
waterfall
flowing steadily downwards no phase
overlaps the other phase
and begins once the previous phase is
complete the steps involved
begin with gathering of requirements and
go up to the phase of maintenance
let's have a look at all the phases in
detail
the first phase is the requirement
gathering phase
as the name implies all the possible
requirements of the project to be
developed
are gathered in this phase and
documented in a requirement
specification document
then comes the system design phase the
requirements gathered in the previous
phase
are studied in this phase and the system
design is prepared
the design helps in specifying all the
requirements
and also helps in defining the overall
system architecture
after the design phase comes the
implementation phase
after the inputs in the system design
phase the system is developed in small
programs
called units these units are integrated
in the upcoming phase here in this phase
each unit
is developed and tested for its
functionality which is referred to as
unit testing now comes the integration
and testing phase all the units
developed in the previous phase
are now integrated into a system post
integration
the entire system is tested for any
faults or failures
after the testing phase comes the
deployment phase
once the entire testing is completed the
functional testing
and the non-functional testing the
product is deployed in the customer
environment
or released into the market now comes
the last phase
that is the maintenance phase the issues
that come up in the client environment
are fixed in this phase then to enhance
the project
some better versions are released
maintenance is done
to deliver these changes in the customer
environment
all these steps or phases are strictly
followed one after the other
like a waterfall moving forth
we know about the waterfall model and
its phases
so let's now see what is the agile
methodology
the agile methodology believes that
every project
is different and needs to be handled
differently
and the existing methods need to be
tailored
to best suit the project requirements
the agile methodology
promotes continuous iteration of
development and testing
all through the software development
life cycle
the process looks forward to quick
delivery of
all the functional components involved
in the project
in agile the tasks are divided into
small time frames
to deliver specific features for a
release
these divisions are known as prints and
these sprints
have their own set of deliverables which
are decided
at the beginning of each sprint
the work can be reviewed by the project
team and the customer
with the help of daily builds and sprint
demos
demo working software is considered to
be the best means of communication
with the customers to understand the
requirements and not just depending
on documentation one of the major
focuses of the agile methodology
is on the customer so the process
involves the customer
throughout the project as the
requirements cannot be gathered
completely in the beginning of the
project
due to various factors continuous
customer interaction
is very important to get proper product
requirements
then there are several phases involved
in the agile software development life
cycle
beginning with the building of concepts
and going up to
the retirement process
the life cycle consists of five
different phases
let's have a look at all these phases in
detail
the first stage of the agile life cycle
is the initiation phase
the initiation phase or the inception
phase is
about the finalization of project scope
and the return on investment
in this step the team members that will
be needed for the project
are identified then time constraint
and other resources required to complete
the project
are also taken into consideration the
second stage in the life cycle
is the planning phase in this phase the
team gets together
and identifies exactly what they are
looking for
they make a firm plan of how to make the
project a success
in this phase the risks are estimated
and the milestones
are developed with an initial release
plan
after the planning phase comes the
development phase
once the requirements have been defined
based on the feedback from the product
owners
and stakeholders the actual work of
development
begins agile product development
delivers
high quality working products in
incremental phases or sprints
then comes the release phase the product
after being developed is now deployed
and starts getting used
by the end users the stages now
are closely monitored for any errors
defects
or bugs that might have been left in the
testing part this phase continues
until the project is fixed with all the
bugs and is ready to be retired
the last in the final stage is the
retirement phase
this last phase marks the deployment of
a newer version of the product
in which all the bugs are fixed there
may be some minor changes of software in
the newer version
and the older version is no longer
supported
the product may also be retired if it is
not cost effective
in the present business scenario
now when we know the basics of the two
sdlc models
and their life cycle phases we shall
differentiate between the waterfall
model
and agile model depending on different
aspects
in software development
the first aspect we will see here is the
life cycle
in the case of agile methodology the
life cycle of the model
is in a continuous iterative format this
helps in developing
and testing a project in several
iterations
whereas in the case of waterfall
methodology the life cycle
is in a linear sequential format where
the development steps
are followed in the form of a top-down
approach
the second difference we will see is on
the basis of rigidity
as we know agile model is a very
flexible way
of building a software in which the
feedback of changes
may be accepted even after the
development has begun
whereas the waterfall model is least
flexible
and the structure of the model is
rigidly followed while developing a
software
the second difference we will see is on
the basis of rigidity
as we know agile model is a very
flexible way
of building a software in which the
feedback or changes
may be accepted even after the
development has become
whereas the waterfall model is least
flexible
and the structure of the model is
rigidly followed
while developing a software
then the next aspect we shall discuss is
collaboration
if we talk about the collaborative
nature of the model then agile model
is very collaborative in nature which
enables it to deliver
a better output and complete the project
in a more productive manner
whereas the waterfall model is not open
for collaborations
it does not allow the team to
collaborate and strictly follows
the sequence of steps
the next important aspect is the process
in the case of agile method the process
is divided into sprints
that have their own deadlines and
deliverables
at the end the waterfall model has a
process of software development
that is broken down into several phases
that go as
a top down approach giving a deliverable
at the end
now after the process the aspect we will
consider
is accepting changes in the case of
agile methodology
the changes can be accepted after the
initial planning is complete
whereas in the case of waterfall model
the development requirements
cannot be changed once the project
development has begun
the next important aspect in our list is
software development
if we consider the agile model the
process of software development
is a collection of many different
projects
as the agile approach completes the
project in several sprints
whereas in the case of waterfall model
software development
is completed as a single project or
deliverable
the next aspect we will discuss is
testing
in the case of agile methodology testing
is performed in the same step
in which programming or building of the
software is being performed
whereas in the waterfall model there is
a separate testing phase
in which the system is tested and this
phase
comes after the build phase we often
come across the question
which development model to choose for
software development
these contrast especially these last
three will help you understand
which model will be a better fit for
your work
the next aspect we will see is focus
that means what the agile or waterfall
model
exactly focuses on so agile model
focuses on customer satisfaction and
performs the steps
with their respective inputs making the
entire process
to be customer centric whereas
the waterfall model strictly focuses on
the steps in the process
and rigidly follows the sequence
it just focuses on completing the
project at the end of the sequential
process
whereas the waterfall model strictly
focuses on the steps in the process
and rigidly follows the sequence it just
focuses on completing the project
or software at the end of the sequential
process
now the next important factor is the
projects
that states which of the two models is a
better fit
for what kind of projects if we talk
about the agile process
it is well suited for projects in which
the requirements
may change whereas if we consider the
waterfall process
it is well suited for well-defined
projects in which
all the requirements are well stated and
no changes are expected
the last crucial contrasting factor is
the customer satisfaction
as we know agile model is customer
centric
and hence involves the customer at every
step of the process
takes their input and implements them
whereas
the waterfall model is an internal
process
that does not involve the customers and
just strictly follows
the sequence of steps
let's talk about what agile is
agile is a very popular principle that
is used in software or project
management
the approach involves creating products
in an incremental manner
from the start of the project rather
than delivering all of it at once
at the end of the project agile
processes
focus on frequent inspection and
adoption
on encouraging teamwork
self-organization
accountability and delivering high
quality software
the business approach is to align
development with the needs of the
customer
and that of the organization now like i
mentioned earlier
the agile process delivers work in small
usable increments for organizations to
take advantage of agile principles
they need to adhere to the values that
are mentioned in the agile manifesto
agile puts individuals and interactions
over process and tools working products
are more important than comprehensive
documentation
customer collaboration is much more
important
than contract negotiation and responding
to changes
cause more significance over following a
plan
with agile the clients in the project
team can have large amounts of
interaction
this helps them understand each other
better
clients have greater transparency to
every phase of the project
the output is delivered in a predictable
manner and sometimes can happen
sooner than expected it provides high
quality development
testing and collaboration due to the
project
being broken down into smaller units
and thanks to continuous evaluation of
requirements
plans and results teams can respond to
change
really fast now let's talk about some
agile methodologies
let's have a look at each of them first
off
xp extreme programming
or xp is a framework with which teams
can create
high quality software it can also
greatly help
improve their quality of life it also
involves the appropriate engineering
practices to enable
software development now it is
applicable for teams handling changing
requirements
while working with smaller teams
handling risks due to new technologies
and much more next up
we have kanban kanban is a visual system
that can help organizations visualize
their workflow
to design manage and to improve the flow
of the systems
now it's applicable in scenarios where
the work is unpredictable
it is also used for deploying work
quickly without having to wait for the
other components
next up we have leave lean provides a
set of tools and services
that focuses on identifying and removing
waste
so that the speed of the process
development can be improved
with lean waste is minimized and value
to the customer
is maximized the principles of lean can
be applied to any sector
which is liable to produce waste
then we have scrum so we'll be taking a
look at scrum in a little bit
but basically scrum is a framework that
involves teams
establishing a hypothesis then trying it
out
reflecting on their experience and
making corresponding adjustments
and finally we have crystal crystal is a
software development approach
that puts people and interactions over
tools and processes
with crystal processes are streamlined
and
optimization is improved
crystal is applicable in scenarios where
the focus is on the team communication
being strengthened now let's have a look
at what scrum is scrum
is a framework through which teams can
work together
with the help of sprints sprints are
events
that are time boxed and are usually of
two to four weeks length
scrum enables teens to learn from their
experiences
self-organize and work on their problems
reflect on their successes
and losses for improvement the team's
progress
is measured with the help of a 15-minute
long daily meeting
called daily scrum during this meeting
team members talk about what they plan
to do on that day
what they did the previous day and what
roadblocks they were facing
with scrum teams can deliver their
projects in an efficient manner
time and money are used effectively
thanks to scrum meetings
visibility is improved and improvements
can be made
thanks to constant feedback from clients
and customers
and so much more now
let's have a look at how scrum works
so here's the entire process let's have
a look at each component
firstly we have product backlog
first a list of all the tasks that need
to be completed
is created now this list is called the
product
backlog now completion of all these
tasks
represent the successful completion of
the project
next we have sprint planning here the
team decides the different tasks that
they are going to work on
and focus on delivering them during the
upcoming sprint
then we have sprint backlog now the
tasks that were discussed in the product
backlog
are then added to this print backlog
which is basically just
another smaller list which consists of
selected items from the product backlog
next up we have the scrum team the scrum
team is a collection of
five to who are working on the tasks
mentioned in the sprint backlog then
we have the daily scrum now this is a
15-minute long session
during which team members can
synchronize their activities
and determine what they did the previous
day what they plan to do on that day
and what roadblocks they were facing
next
up sprint review now after a sprint is
complete
a meeting involving the scrum team scrum
master
product owner and stakeholders take
place
during this meeting the team shows off
what they accomplished
during the sprint questions are asked
observations are made feedback and
suggestions are also provided
now back to the product backlog now the
product backlog is presented to the
stakeholders
so that the product owner can get some
feedback for upcoming sprints
then there's also the sprint
retrospective
now during this meeting previous
mistakes are identified
and new ways to handle them are
determined
the data that's obtained from this
meeting is also used while planning the
news trend
and finally we have increment now in
this stage
a workable output is provided to the
stakeholders
and after this another sprint starts and
the whole process is repeated again
now let's talk about strum versus agile
firstly let's have a look at
methodologies
now agile is a set of principles that
are iterative
and incremental agile has a number of
different methodologies
you can choose from there's xp crystal
kanban
even scrum for that matter let's talk
about scrum now
scrum is an implementation of the
concepts of agile
so basically most of the important
components of
agile can be applied to scrum as well
it provides the customer with
incremental builds
that are delivered to the customer in
the span of two to four weeks
an organization can be agile but not
practice crowd however an organization
cannot practice scrum
without being agile next up
let's have a look at projects agile is
more
suited towards projects that have a
small development team
that consists of experts whereas on the
side of scrum
it's usually better suited for projects
that are subject to a large amount of
change
and that will rapidly next
we have leadership now for agile a
project head takes care of all the tasks
and has a very important role to play in
the process of a job
a project head represents the entire
team and is responsible for getting
issues resolved
by assigning them to the appropriate
members of the team
in scrum there's no leader there's a
scrum master who can overall
guide the sprint process but the team
addresses issues by themselves
it usually involves cross-functional and
self-organizing teams
next up we have flexibility agile is
relatively more rigid than scrum
and cannot handle changes with these it
also requires a lot of upfront
development process
and changes within the organization with
scrum
you can enable team delivery agile
requires
frequent deliveries so that they can get
feedback from the end user
this in turn will help make the product
better
the product is delivered as well as
updated on a regular basis
with scrum after a sprint feedback from
the client for a build
is provided to the team scrum involves
daily scrum meetings to review
and get feedback to determine the next
steps of the project
the next print is only planned by the
team after the current sprint is
complete
next we have collaboration with agile
collaboration involves face-to-face
interactions with team members of other
cross-functional teams
for scrum daily stand-up meetings take
place with specific roles
like scrum master product owner and the
scrum team
and finally we have design with agile
the design
as well as its execution it's relatively
simple
with scrum the design and its execution
can be innovative
and experimental so you might be
wondering
which one should you choose now among
both these options there's one thing
that will remain common
agile now what you can decide upon
is which agile methodology you will be
choosing
is it lean is it canvan or is it scrum
let's jump into scrum versus kanban so
before we dive
into the differences between scrum and
kanban let's have a look
at what exactly scrum is
scrum is a simple agile project
management framework
that is used by organizations to help
teams collaborate
handle unpredictability and complex
projects or products
while ensuring the products delivered
are of the highest value
it describes a set of meetings tools and
roles
that enable teams to work in sync and
help them structure themselves
and manage their work scrum is one of
those things
that's really easy to understand but
very difficult to master
and although scrum is seen to be used
generally by software development teams
its principles and themes are pretty
universal and can be used with just
about
all kinds of teamwork with scrum
teams are able to learn from their
experiences
what worked out what didn't and things
like that
they're also able to organize themselves
to handle their problems
effectively and basically improve
themselves
by reflecting on them
so how does scrum work
here we have the first component the
product backlog
the product backlog consists of a list
of tasks
that need to be completed so that the
goals of the stakeholders are achieved
then the team decides what tasks from
the product backlog
they want to take up and deliver in a
two to four week period
called sprint hence the name sprint
planning
next the tasks that were discussed in
the previous phase
are added to the sprint backlog this is
a set of tasks
which will be focused on in the ongoing
sprint
following this the scrum team which is
usually
5 to 9 members strong will work on these
tasks
now they also have regular scrum
meetings where they talk about their
victories
the issues they face and what they plan
to do in the next 24 hours
and then they have the sprint review the
sprint review is a meeting
during which the team shows what they
accomplished during the sprint
now during this time questions are asked
observations
feedback and suggestions are made the
product owner
also gets feedback for upcoming sprints
from stakeholders
they also have a sprint retrospective
now during this session past mistakes
potential issues
and new ways to handle them are
identified
data from here is incorporated into the
new sprint plan
the final step is increment here
a workable and usable output is provided
to the stakeholders
so now that we know how scrum works
let's have a look at kanban
kanban comes from the japanese word
kanbam
which literally means signboard
like scrum kanban is a popular agile
framework
that is a visual system by which the
work can be managed with ease
as it progresses kanban uses something
known as the kanban board
to make these things possible with this
you can easily identify bottlenecks
and then fix them cost effectively at
optimal speeds
the main focus with kanban is
transparency
since everything related to the tasks
are on the board
everyone can keep themselves updated
it also ensures the teams focus on their
current tasks
until they're done this limits the
amount of work
that's in progress
so on the kanban board work is divided
into smaller
more manageable pieces the work that's
needed to be done
is written on a note or card and placed
on a board
columns on the board help represent
where each item is
with respect to the workflow now let's
have a look at what these are in detail
let's find out how kanban works
now the board consists of three major
components
that's the to-do list which represents
items that need to be completed
the ongoing column which represents
items that are being currently worked on
and the completed or the done column now
these represent
tasks or items that have already been
completed
now although this is a physical
representation of the board
several organizations use software
versions of the board
that replaces the sticky notes with
cards that can be moved
from one column to another as work
progresses
at this point you guys must have
realized how similar these two
frameworks sound
so let's run through some more of their
similarities
let's find out how they are similar
firstly they both have principles of
lean and agile
which means reduction of waste and both
of them are time boxed
and iterative approaches that enable
product delivery
in an incremental manner
both these frameworks aim to reduce the
amount of work in progress
this forces the teams to ensure that
they focus on a smaller set of tasks
this also makes blockers and bottlenecks
a little more visible
in both cases the work is divided into
smaller
more manageable units
both of these frameworks use pull
scheduling
now this means the products are only
built based on demand
rather than forecasts
transparency plays a major role in both
these frameworks
by helping them drive process
improvement
and in both cases the release plan is
continuously optimized
and finally both these methods aim to
deliver releasable software
often and earlier than expected now
let's have a look at how these two
frameworks are different from one
another
firstly let's have a look at cadence
cadence refers to the amount
of time in a sprint or before a release
so when it comes to scrum the entire
project is divided into time constrained
iterations
that is into smaller manageable units
but when it comes to kanban it's even
driven
the next criteria we're going to have a
look at
is release methodology
in scrum releases take place after each
sprint
which usually takes two to four weeks to
complete
for kanban releases take place in the
form of continuous delivery
they happen in such a way that changes
like new features
configuration changes bug fixes and
experiments
get to the users in a safe quick and
sustainable manner
next up let's have a look at how changes
are addressed in both these frameworks
in scrum no change can be made while
this print is in progress
once it's complete changes can be
considered in the sprint plan
and then added to the sprint backlog
with kanban
changes can be made at any time and
incorporated into the workflow
now let's consider the metric that's
being measured
in scrum for planning and process
improvement
velocity which is the measure of the
work that can be completed by a team in
a sprint
is the key metric in kanban
lead time is the key metric this
represents the period of time between a
new task's appearance in your workflow
and its final departure from the system
next let's have a look at how teams work
in these frameworks
in scrum you need a cross-functional
team
to achieve your goals in a sprint in
kanban
cross-functional teams are optional but
specialized themes
that focus on particular aspects of the
workflow are required
now let's talk about new additions
in scrum just like handling changes you
can't add
any items between a sprint or nitration
in kanban new items can be added to the
board
as long as there is capacity available
for it
now let's have a look at the job roles
within these frameworks
scrum has three major job roles product
owner
scrum master and scrum team
with kanban you don't have any specific
job roles
now let's talk about representation or
moreover
let's talk about how data can be
represented
with scrum the board needs to be reset
once a particular sprint is complete
with kanban the board stays persistent
throughout the entirety of the project
and finally let's have a look at project
link
with scrum it's better suited for longer
projects
and with kanban projects that can be
completed in a shorter period of time
are better so which one should you
choose
now selecting from these two methods is
mainly based on the requirements of the
team
do you expect your project to be shorter
do you want to make changes at any
time you don't want to set up
job-specific roles
then kanban is the framework for you or
do you want a long-running project
with different job roles and involving
cross-functional teams
scrum is the answer for you based on the
differences we discussed on the last
topic
you can make an informed decision now
let's have a look at some of the popular
companies around the world
that employ both these frameworks
some of the companies that have
successfully implemented scrum
are facebook general electronics and
adobe
companies that have implemented kanban
are siemens
bbc and sap
today we will learn how to become a
certified
scrum master so without further ado
let's get started so here we have two
people
let's call them jim and pam
here we see jim introducing himself to
pam
and the team as their new scrum master
pam is now expressing interest in
becoming a scrum master herself
and is asking for some guidance from jen
happy to help jim starts
first let's talk about scrum what
exactly is it
scrum is an extremely popular agile
framework
which enables teams to work together
while working on a complex project
or a product scrum helps teams to
self-organize
to learn from their experiences and to
reflect on their
victories and losses for improvement
although commonly used in software
development
the concept of scrum can be applied to
any kind of team
it's basically a collection of meetings
tools
and rules that help the team structure
and manage their work
let's talk about some advantages of
scrum
first of all it improves the quality of
product development
with scrum you are able to develop
complex products
in less complicated process teams are
able to constantly make
improvements to their product thanks to
the input and feedback
from their customers next it provides
faster delivery of projects now this can
be an extension of
previous point thanks to the real-time
updates
from stakeholders or end users the team
is able to immediately address the
changes
this enables the project to be delivered
at a faster pace
then scrum gives you a high return on
investment or
roi scrum enables you to deliver
projects but decrease time to market
thanks to the results being delivered
early it gives
stakeholders to further reinvest
it also proves the worthiness of the
project to the stakeholders
who are interested next scrum enables
self-sufficiency and creativity
it enables team members to be creative
with problem solving
and to take a hands-on approach to the
project
and since decisions are taken by each
member of the team
the make sure of their own
self-sufficiency
and finally it improves customer
satisfaction
thanks to the constant involvement with
each phase of the project
with feedback and interactions the final
product is more
likely to be in a form that they'll
appreciate
next let's talk about the role of a
scrum master
a scrum master is an individual who
promotes and
supports the usage of scrum practices in
the team and the organization
scrum masters have a high level view of
the project
and help team members perform their
tasks better
without having to deal with obstacles
and distractions
a scrum master helps the team understand
the theory
rules and values of scrum considering
there are
many moving parts in a project the scrum
master enables the business
the product owner the scrum and other
individuals to work together
in harmony now let us talk about the
responsibilities of a scrum master
a scrum master ensures that the product
owner
and development team follow scrum values
principles
and practices this can help teamwork
effectively and provide high quality
results
the scrum master also ensures the team's
productivity
isn't affected by any blockage
if the problem can be solved by the team
members on their own
the scrum master helps the scrum master
accesses different blockage and
prioritizes solving
each one of them the scrum master also
protects the team from any distraction
and any external interference to make
sure that they are able to deliver value
at the end of
each and every sprint a scrum master
ensures that
the team isn't involved in any
irrelevant discussions and
focuses on the sprint's requirements the
scrum master
also has different roles to play with
specific components of the scrum process
like the product owner the scrum team
and the organization now let's have a
look on the scrum master's
responsibilities
to the product owner the scrum master
makes sure the goals scope and product
domain are understood by
everyone in the team the scrum master
needs to find a way to effectively
manage the product backlog
this helps the scrum team understand why
their product backlog
needs to be clear and concise the scrum
master
needs to ensure the product backlog is
arranged properly
and to facilitate scrum events like
sprint retrospectives
sprint planning sessions daily scrum
events
now let's have a look at how a scrum
masters
is responsible to the scrum team to
develop
the team to self-organize and to enable
cross-functionality
with teams to help the team create
products of
high value to remove roadblocks that the
team may
encounter the scrum team needs to
facilitate scrum events like they are
required
now moving ahead the scrum master helps
the organization
to lead and coach its adoption for scrum
the scrum master helps to plan the
implementation of
scrum the scrum master needs to help the
employees
as well as stakeholders the scrum master
helps to understand how scrum helps to
increase the value produced
and finally the scrum master helps to
make changes
that increase the scrum team's
productivity and more
now let's talk about how can you become
a scrum master
first you need to have a strong
understanding of scrum and
agile concepts as a scrum master
you need to ensure that your team
follows the principles of
agile and scrum you need to have a
clear understanding of different teams
and phases
within scrum to ensure you can
understand and teach
the usage of framework to the
organization properly
in short having a detailed understanding
of the systems
and terminologies is mandatory
a scrum certification can also greatly
help
with this more on that in a little bit
you need
fine-tuned organizational skills you
need to be able to structure the team
and plan out their actions to ensure
everything stays
organized and to make sure everything
stays
on track you need the ability to plan
things out
you should be able to ensure that the
team stays
on schedule and all the tasks are
completed successfully you could also
use online project management systems
like
monday.com nutcase and sam 9000
to keep things organized you need to be
familiar
with the technology the team uses you
need to ensure that
the team is able to complete their
project in a timely manner
this can be done if you have an
understanding of different
technical terms and processes that the
team is involved with
hence some technical familiarity and
training
is really important you also need to
have the ability to coach and
teach the team to follow scrum properly
for teams that are new to the scrum
methodology
your ability to teach them the different
concepts
terms and principles play a very
important role in the future success of
the team
you need to be able to tell the team not
only what it needs to be done
but also how and why you
also need to be able to increase the
team members
to work together and improve themselves
you may also need to work with
individual team members to maximize
their potential
you need to have the ability to handle
conflicts and
resolve them quickly considering how
teams are filled with people
with different personalities ideas and
working styles
it is only likely that they may clash
with each other
every now and then if disagreement
cannot be handled among themselves
you need to be able to figure things out
if left unsolved
this could inhibit the entire team's
progress
so you must be able to negotiate and
resolve the conflict
in a way that satisfies everyone
and finally you must be a servant leader
a servant leader puts the needs of the
team before their own
and helps each member to perform the
best of their capabilities
you need to be both a leader and the
team member
you need to be the part of your team
while making sure
they can successfully fulfill their
requirements
now let's talk about certifications
to become a scrum master at a certified
one at that
one of the most important things you can
do is
to get through the certified scrum
master test
this test tests your understanding of
different principles and
processes that are the part of scrum
process
moreover to take this test you need to
have completed an
in-person or an online course taught by
a certified scrum trainer
or certified agile coach you'll also
need to have
at least 14 hours of face-to-face
interaction
with the aforementioned trainer or a
coach
let's get to the exam the exam is of 1r
and it has 50 questions in it and you
need to score at least
37 to pass the exam the exam costs
around 29 to 30 dollars
and you have two attempts to clear after
90 days or
two attempts you'll need to pay 25
to write the exam again once you are
certified
you'll need to re-certify yourself by
taking an exam again
after two years now let's talk about the
salary of
a scrum master according to glassdoor
the united states of america a scrum
master earns
approximately 97 000
u.s dollars per annum meanwhile
in india a scrum master can earn
up to 14 lakh rupees per annum
hyped up about becoming a scrum master
yet let me now tell you about
how simply learn can help simply learn
offers
the certified scrum master certification
training course
so in simply learn certified scrum
master certification
we will be providing you with scrum and
agile methodologies
importance of agile scrum lifecycle
scrum terminologies roles involved in
scrum
and much more so take your first step to
getting certified
and getting ahead in your career by
clicking on the top
right corner and enrolling with simply
learn
and with that we have come to the end of
this full course video
on agile and scrum i hope it was
informative
and interesting if you have any
questions related to the topics
covered in this video please ask away in
the comment section below
our team will help you solve your
queries at the earliest
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here